bonsoir mesdames et messieurs bon
dimanche soir bienvenue à ce grand
rendez vous électoral peut-être ce soir
ce sera la première vraie occasion vous
aurez de vous intéresser à la campagne
électorale avec moi céline et anne-marie
bonsoir bonsoir nous sommes payés pour
nous intéresser à chaque détail de cette
campagne depuis le début mais je pense
que ça mentir on peut dire que les gens
sont tirer l'oreille un peu pour s'y
intéresse on est en plein été pandémie
etc ouais il ya sûrement des gens qui se
demandent encore pourquoi cette élection
a été déclenché et on espère qu'ils
auront 10 réponse ce soir justement ces
privilégiés donner la parole au chef les
cinq en même temps on attend beaucoup de
leurs réponses alors on compte sur eux
oui et c'est une et quand quand trois
chefs d'antenne les chefs en direct ce
soir nous poserons mesdames et messieurs
des questions donc aux cinq chefs
invités à tour de rôle ce n'est pas le
débat sur le débat c'est le 8 septembre
prochain ce soir il s'agit de cinq
entrevues donc en direct les chefs qui
sont arrivés à radio canada il ya
quelques minutes prendront place à tour
de rôle et je vous indique que l'ordre a
été déterminée selon le nombre de
députés élus pour chaque partie premier
chef invité donc justin trudeau
les canadiens doivent se sentir fr
colline en ce moment important deux
décisions pour notre pays
nous sommes très très clair que les
fonctionnaires fédéraux doivent se faire
vacciner on est en train de finir notre
le contrat qu'avait 19 faut continuer de
se fier à la science
le gouvernement fédéral va là avec 9
milliards de dollars travaillant avec
les provinces en respectant leurs
juridictions non s'assurant que partout
au pays nos aînés soient protégés et je
suis aussi tout à fait d'accord avec les
provinces qu'il faut augmenter les
transferts en santé
c'est le moment de continuer notre lutte
contre les changements climatiques avec
encore plus de vraies actions la liberté
de choix être pro choix c'est pas une
question de choix pour les médecins
c'est une question de choix pour les
femmes je continue d'avoir de parler
encore plus dangereux d'automne et
comment les canadiens veulent qu'on
avance mieux sur le chemin de la
réconciliation au parti libéral on va
continuer à développer des vraies
solutions qui fonctionnent pour tout le
monde
monsieur trudeau bonjour bonsoir je
trudeau je vais pas vous demander ce à
toutes les missions mais la petite
exception oui ou non si possible pour
les deux petites première question est
ce que vous regrettez
cette campagne qui était pas tellement
désirée par les canadiens non la réalité
c'est que je comprends que les gens ça
leur tente pas d'aller en élection ça
leur tente on ne reviennent pas tant
leur tampon ne vient de passer une année
difficile limite difficile on veut la
reprise on veut avancer mais il ya des
grosses décisions à prendre en tant que
pays sur comment en finir avec la
pandémie comment on va continuer les
gens méritent de pouvoir faire le choix
c'est votre troisième campagne fédérale
monsieur trudeau peu importe le résultat
ce que ça sera la dernière ils n'ont pas
nécessairement
et
je pense pas à ça je pense à tout ce
qu'on est en train de faire ensemble et
tout ce que je veux pouvoir faire et
c'est pour ça que avec les décisions qui
vont se prendre dans les mois à venir
pendant un an pendant deux ans mais
maintenant je suis excité j'anticipe
beaucoup les responsabilités qu'on va
voir ensemble en même temps mais ce
trudeau la quatrième vague on le voit
elle s'accélère le nombre de cas
augmente au pays vous êtes en train dé
si vous faire réélire plutôt que de
diriger les opérations alors est ce que
cette campagne électorale elle ne nuit
pas quand même aux efforts pour
combattre la pandémie tout d'abord on
comprend que cette quatrième vague une
vague surtout des non vaccinés il ya la
plupart des canadiens presque 80% des
un régime qui se sont fait vacciner ils
ont fait leur d'avoir on est en train
passe à travers pour beaucoup de gens
qui n'ont pas de problème avec les
vaccins les masses tout ça oui il faut
continuer d'être vigilant il faut
continuer d'encourager tout le monde de
se faire vacciner mais on peut aussi
commencent à reprendre la vraie vie et
de comprendre que oui c'est un moment on
a appris comment gérer une grise immense
et on doit appliquer ces mêmes
réflexions à la crise climatique à la
crise du logement on a des grosses
décisions à prendre maintenant puis
c'est important que les canadiens se
fassent entendre par leur vote monsieur
trudeau vous a dit quand même les moyens
faut compléter vos engagements vous
devez laisser des projets sur la table
non complétées et là vous êtes
confrontés ma foi une vague de rage
par la crise de la pandémie au fond est
avec cette vague d'orages est ce qu'on
peut pas se demander si cette élection
ne devient pas un référendum sur vos
clés du chèque à vous je pense pas parce
que on voit là la vague de rage oui des
gens qui refusent de se faire vacciner
il ya des gens qui sont en train de
manifester de façon assez intense et
même violente mais c'est une petite
minorité on voit le canada et est à la
tête de la planète en termes de
vaccination les gens veulent qu'on passe
à travers on appris des grosses
décisions on va continuer d'en prendre
mais c'est normal que quand on prend
deux grosses décisions on veuille la
confiance et l'appui de la population
directement en 2019 on n'a pas parlé de
pandémie qui on est déjà rendu le 5e
plus long gouvernement minoritaire dans
l'histoire du pays je pense que dans une
crise comme ça dans un moment pivot
comme ça oui on devrait vérifier avec
les gens qu'on va aller encore plus vite
pour les changements climatiques on va
aller encore plus vite pour les familles
pour les vénérables si ce qu'ont appris
pendant la pandémie avant d'avancer je
pense que ces deux mises d'avoir une
élection ce trudeau le trait zhu deux
jours avant le déclenchement j'avais
annoncé la vaccination obligatoire pour
tous les fonctionnaires fédéraux
qu'est ce qui va arriver aux
fonctionnaires qui refusent de se faire
vacciner air canada c'est clair pas de
vaccin pas d'emploi quelle est votre
position
mais c'est aussi très clair pas de
vaccination vous allez pouvoir embarquer
dans l'avion cet automne ne vais pas
pouvoir prendre un train alors ça c'est
quelque chose d'important qu'on a prise
comme décision mais on l'avait pas non
c'est juste la veille de l'élection on
en avait parlé une semaine deux semaines
avant que je vais fait une annonce avec
monsieur legault sur les garderies donc
les gens voyaient souvenir évidemment on
va travailler avec les syndicats on va
travailler avec les employeurs dans la
fonction publique pour s'assurer que oui
c'était pas vacciner tu pourras pas
travailler
tu pourras pas travailler doit présenter
au travail au bureau parce que ça met
les autres à risque bon vous avez vu les
manifestants vendredi évidemment et là
ça on a l'impression que ça va aller en
s'accélérant ces manifestations la
qu'est-ce que vous êtes aux
fonctionnaires de revenu canada qui
travaillent dans son sous-sol à toronto
ou à gatineau à shawinigan pourquoi lui
devrait se faire avec tout d'abord je
dire merci aux fonctionnaires de revenu
canada parce que c'est eux qui ont livré
la pci e 6 e qui ont été là pour aider
avec des mesures extraordinaires pour
qu'on puisse passer à travers de cette
pandémie et qu'ils l'ont fait d'ailleurs
à partir de leur sous-sol de leur dans
leur salon
deuxièmement la fonction publique au
canada est déjà
extrêmement extrêmement haut niveau de
vaccination donc on voit que c'est des
gens qui respectent la science oui il ya
des gens qui veulent faire le choix de
ne pas se faire vacciner mais ils
pourront pas mettre les autres à risque
par des gens ils ont fait leur devoir
ils comprennent que de se faire vacciner
c'est pas juste de se protéger soi même
c'est de protéger les autres c'est de
protéger nos aînés c'est de protéger nos
enfants que mon enfant de 7 ans qui
propose faire vacciner il faut que tout
le monde a sa part ok mais conséquence
mais qui sont à définir avec les
syndicats ne sais pas qu'est ce qui va
arriver à quelqu'un qui refuse
effectivement mais on peut être très
très clair pour les voyageurs par
exemple et on a on appris des choix très
clair et d'ailleurs le fait qu' un débat
là-dessus dans cette élection souligne à
quel point oui des gros choix à prendre
très bien parlant de débord vous
promettez depuis début de la campagne
des milliards 10 milliards aux provinces
pour la santé pour engager des médecins
des infirmières pour les les attend pour
les sachets celle d'el et les maisons
pour personnes âgées
monsieur legault vous a répondu cette
semaine et le jeu site il a dit hey je
les bras aux médecins et moi j'ai besoin
d'argent mais sans condition est-ce que
c'est clair pour régler cette histoire
leur qui n'y aura pas un transfert sans
conditions vers les problèmes ce que les
gens veulent selon ce que les gens ont
besoin c'est les mon service kylie qui
font un impact dans leur vie pour eux
oui on va toujours respecté les champs
de compétences qu'on va le faire au
partenariat mais on a pu le faire
pendant un an et demi déjà avec des
transferts pour la pandémie avec des
partenariats j'ai signé énormément
d'accord avec monsieur legault justement
pour livrer de l'argent directement dans
les poches pour la pandémie on va
continuer de le faire mais on va
s'assurer que ce soit l'argent qui va à
la bonne place pour vraiment livré pour
les gens et on a confiance dans les
provinces dans les choix qui vont juste
pour être clair mme se trouvait le 28
milliards sans condition que vous
demandent les provinces oui ça arrivera
jamais on va en discuter mais on a
démontré qu'on ait la dent pendant la
crise et on sera là pour l'avenir aussi
pcr eu beaucoup de gens qui se plaignent
de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui fait
mal partout pays vous dise fermez le
robinet c'est à six à huit cent mille
canadiens encore qui touche la cette
prestation d'urgence est ce que vous
allez la reconduire de mois en mois
jusqu'à l'éternité non évidemment non et
on a déjà réduite jusqu'à 500 $ par
semaine
damman jusqu'à 300 dollars par semaine
plutôt que le 500 parce que il ya un
moins grand besoin avec la reprise
économique mais aussi aussi qu'il ya
certains secteurs dont les arts la
culture par exemple où les gens on
arrache encore à cause de cette pandémie
qui continue on n'est pas tout à fait de
retour à la normale donc on va continuer
d'être là pour les gens qui ont en
besoin la pénurie de main d'oeuvre elle
était là avant la pandémie c'est sûr que
la pandémie est exacerbée certaines
conditions certaines situations mais on
va continuer de travailler
des pénuries de main-d'oeuvre vous
faites quoi l'immigration la formation
mais on reconnaît aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui pendant cette pause
pandémie d'un an d'un an et demi on
réfléchit à leur carrière à leur
direction ils veulent pas revenir dans
les mêmes emplois qu'ils avaient avant
c'est quelque chose qui arrive on va
être là pour les soutenir on voit aussi
être l'ordre les employeurs ce qui amène
un déficit énorme où on s'est retourné
en étant raynaud vendredi on sort la
réunion prof 1 milliards de plus pour le
passeport vaccinale ce trudeau il ya des
gens qui commencent sérieusement à
s'inquiéter en dix ans qu'on voit pour
refiler une facture et éhontée à nos
enfants
commençons d'abord par comprendre que
quand il a fallu qu'on passe à un arrêt
de l'économie à cause de la pandémie
fallait qu'on soit là pour appuyer les
gens parce que ils n'allaient pas
pouvoir payer leur loyer à payer leur
épicerie donc on était là heureusement
on avait le meilleur bilan économique
d'angers 7 on appuie donc est versée
pour aider les gens pour les empêcher de
voir mettre leurs loyers sur leur carte
de crédit par exemple payer 19 %
d'impôts pardon d'intérêt pendant que
nous en gouvernement fédéral on en prend
à peine 1% on sait aussi qu'on arrive et
si on s'est endetté pour que les gens et
pas à s'endetter et sur ses projets ce
la bonne raison pour pour des raisons
morales c'est la bonne chose à faire
parce que ça nous a permis de passer à
travers et de rouvrir de façon plus
rapide nous notre économie mais le plein
de retours 30 secondes dans ce bloc le
plan le retour à une équipe ebr on
dirait que ça vous préoccupe pas du tout
au contraire on a démontré dans le
budget 2010 2021 il ya quelques mois
qu'on va continuer de baisser la dette
comme pourcentage de notre pib donc on
reste dans sur une
direction responsable même avec tous les
investissements qu'on est en train de
faire les garderies 30 milliards de
dollars pour des garderies à travers le
pays les gens disent oh mon dieu c'est
trop cher monsieur autour dit oh mon
dieu c'est trop cher faudrait pas le
faire il va renverser ça mais on le sait
que des garderies les places en garderie
c'est bon pour les familles c'est bon
pour l'économie aussi monsieur trudeau
parlons de l'afghanistan parce que vous
saviez depuis le printemps que les
américains allaient se retirer que les
talibans pouvaient prendre le pouvoir
pourquoi est ce que le canada a tant
tardé à commencer leur rapatriement de
ces afghans qui ont travaillé avec les
canadiens parfois au péril de leur vie
quoi s'attarder autant sa pote tarder
autant on a travaillé avec les
communautés on a travaillé avec les
anciens interprète afghan a pour
justement commencé le processus on a pu
rapatrier autour de 3700 avec 10 ses
vols tout au long du mois du mois d'août
on aurait voulu en faire plus mais on
était limité par la situation avec les
talibans par les américains par les vols
qui peut rentrer et sortir mais on
n'abandonne pas on continue le travail
parce que on s'attend à en accueillir
des dizaines de milliers au canada c'est
ce que les canadiens et québécois
veulent ils veulent reconnaître ces gens
là qui qui fuient la terreur on va être
là pour eux on va continuer le travail
mais sur le coup en regard des saints on
voyait bien que pour tous les pays c'est
assez chaotique tout le monde a été pris
par surprise mais on a le sentiment
quand même que pour le canada ça a été
plus compliqué il y avait des pays qui
ont gardé une représentation
diplomatique sur place qui était à
l'aéroport qui pouvait accueillir les
gens qui allaient en l'autobus les
chercher qui les amenait qu'il y faisait
passer à travers cette foule qu'elle
veut à travers ces barrages d'aliments
le canada n'a pas fait ça au contraire
aux 900 avait des membres des forces
armées qui sont alléchants chez des gens
et c'est pour ça que le canada se
compare très bien au nombre de
ressortissants aux etats-unis à la
grande-bretagne qui avaient une plus
grande équipe sur terrain mais tous les
autres pays européens on se compare très
favorablement on a fait énormément parce
que on est là pour les gens et surtout
on est prêt à en accueillir beaucoup
plus que d'autres pays mais il y avait
beaucoup de militaires qui ont
l'impression qu'on les a abandonnés
quand même six avions est ce que vous
avez à vous partager ce sentiment je
comprends à quel point c'est extrêmement
difficile cette situation c'est à
déchirer le coeur de voir les taliban
prendre contrôle après 20 ans on a
travaillé sur le terrain avec tant de
sacrifices avec tant de pertes de vies
et d'efforts et d'argent canadien
investi là-dedans ça brise le coeur et
on va continuer d'être là m'ont
accueilli pardon comment vous à l'elysée
dès maintenant comment faire sortir du
pays à six restent à peu près 300
familles on nous dit 2000 personnes on
va en accueillir beaucoup plus que ça on
est en train de travailler des
partenaires dans les régions pour voir
s'il est restreint de mettre la paire de
fréhel des gens qui ont travaillé dans
celle de la pression sur les talibans
pour s'assurer que des gens qui ont la
documentation canadiennes puissent
sortir on a des partenaires régionaux
qui vont aider à ce niveau là on va
aussi travailler avec les pays
avoisinants pour pouvoir ramener les
gens qui ont fui des revers d'autres
pays ça va pas être facile c'est une
situation désastreuse en afghanistan
c'est vraiment difficile et pénible
voire mais on va continuer de faire tout
ce qu'on peut pour sauver le plus de
gens possible parce que c'est ce que les
canadiens s'attendent de nous est-ce que
vous avez été déçu de ne pas avoir été
informés des détails de ce retrait des
américains
au contraire tout pendant ce processus
là on a eu des échanges réguliers avec
tous nos alliés avec j'ai parlé au
président j'ai parlé à bien du monde
président biden pendant la rencontre du
g7 mais mes ministres ont parlé
directement à leurs homologues on était
extrêmement coordonner les forces armées
canadiennes étaient et intégrée est
partenaire avec les forces américaines
comme on l'est donc la relation avec les
états unis elle vaut bien votre avenir
parce qu'on se demande qu'est ce qui se
passe avec la frontière par exemple
comment ça se fait comment expliquer
qu'on l'ait pas réussi à coordonner une
ouverture simultanée des deux côtés vous
avez ouvert de votre côté les américains
empêchent encore les canadiens de
rentrer par la frontière terrestre sauf
que les américains ils permettaient les
gens d'aller en floride à noël qu'ils
soient vaccinées ou non et nous on
permettait pas aux américaines donc il y
avait toujours communication la tiens
vous avez pas vous n'arrivez pas à vous
faire entendre et finissent pas au
contraire on a toujours très bien
coordonnées mais chaque pays va prendre
ses propres décisions pour gérer la
pandémie on a vu que la pandémie était
différente au canada qu'elle a été aux
états unis parce qu'on a géré
différemment et je pense qu'on a très
bien géré la pandémie merci monsieur
truc mais ce trudeau la planète brûle
des images de catastrophes même du
canada ont fait le tour du monde on sait
par le giec notamment que le canada va
se réchauffer deux fois plus vite que
les autres pays mais le nord trois fois
puis v et quand vous avez fait de
nouvelles annonces pour vos cibles il ya
quelques semaines quelques mois vous
avez annoncé des cibles inférieure à
celle des états unis alors on peut se
demander pourquoi vous n'avez pas le
même sentiment d'urgence face à cette
crise des changements climatiques que
les états unis je comprends que les
cibles sont importantes et on est on est
des cibles extrêmement ambitieuse
jusqu'à 45 % en dessous des niveaux de
2003 à 2005 en 2030 mais l'important
c'est le niveau d'ambition qu'on craint
connu pour pouvoir réaliser on a au
cours des 5 5 6 dernières années mis un
prix sur la pollution partout au pays on
a banni les plastiques à usage nocifs
aujourd'hui j'ai annoncé que les
émissions du secteur pétrolier ne vont
que des cendres ne vont que baisser dans
les années à venir il y aura plus
d'expansion au vu de l'accroissement des
émissions on est en train d'avoir un
plan extrêmement ambitieux mais aussi
extrêmement réaliste et pratique mais
moins moins ambitieux que celui des
états unis les états unis de prix sur la
pollution nous on a une des plus la
pollution les plus les plus robustes au
monde alors avec tout ce que vous avez
nommé ray de vos réalisations
comment expliquer que le canada était le
seul pays du g7 avoir augmenté ses
émissions de gaz et chatin parce que
pendant dix ans quand on a pris le
pouvoir on avait un gouvernement qui n'a
rien fait pour lutter pour compte les
changements climatiques et il a fallu
qu'on commence à zéro en 2015 et 2 0 on
est arrivé maintenant avec une approche
qui va nous amener à
dépasser largement les sites de monsieur
harper sauf évidemment si monsieur
o'toole nous ramène en arrière comme il
veut il veut reprendre les mêmes sites
d'art peur qu'on a déjà dépassé on a
beaucoup plus à faire on a démontré
notre capacité de le faire mais vous
avez mis plusieurs années à rajuster
bosse il faut bien le reconnaître vous
voyez parce qu'on sait pose une question
de donner c'est n'importe qui peut
donner des cibles est-ce qu'on peut
créer un plan pour y arriver dans un
pays qui est trop fois l'hiver trop
chaud l'été où les espaces sont vastes
oui on est juste un ami le travail pour
faire un plan concret qui veulent livrer
cette ambition le rapport du giec encore
une fois cet été a lancé vraiment une
alerte rouge pour l'humanité interpelle
aussi le canada allez-vous mettre fin
aux subventions mesures fiscales très
grand titre est aux industries fossiles
au fond c'est quand la fin de la
récréation ce trou d'eau c'est
maintenant c'est depuis plusieurs années
qu'on a mis un prix sur la pollution à
travers le pays la réalité c'est que
l'honneur et on est en voie d'éliminer
les
distri les subventions aux industries
sauf que à l'intérieur des subventions
qui sont cités souvent par le npd on a
des investissements pour convertir des
usines d'acier pour utiliser
l'électricité plutôt qu'un charbon on a
des mesures pour pour aider l'industrie
pétrolière à réduire leur méthane on est
en train de mettre des mesures
conditionnelle pour améliorer l'elysée
mission parce que veut pas l'alberta et
l'industrie pétrolière va devoir faire
partie de notre avenir nette zéro et
c'est justement avec leur innovation et
leur leadership et leur emploi qu'on va
y arriver où il ya quand même
transporter les poursuivre le projet pas
question de l'intérêt hong hao ne put on
veut limiter les les augmentations des
missions on va les réduire et un oléoduc
et c'est la meilleure façon la moins
polluante de transporter du pétrole
pendant qu'on en a besoin et réduire les
productions oui oui on veut réduire les
émissions surtout si les émissions qui
sont inquiétants on voit on va continuer
a besoin de pétrole pendant quelques
années mais si on peut décarboniser si
on peut innover pour réduire l'impact
pendant qu'on a des voitures encore à
carburants fossiles c'est mieux pour
nous c'est mieux pour l'environnement
vous avez annoncé justement aujourd'hui
des mesures mais on n'a toujours pas de
programme pourquoi avoir annoncé vos
mesures sur les changements climatiques
aujourd'hui en dehors de l'ensemble des
programmes qu'on a une vision d'ensemble
la vision d'ensemble
elle est là dans notre notre vision de à
des 100% vie que l'électrique en 2035
50% de nouveaux véhicules par an d'ici
2030 on est là avec un plan ambitieux et
la plateforme entière va sortir dans les
jours à venir est ce que ça prend pour
un électrochoc
pour lutter contre les changements
climatiques oui mais c'est exactement ce
qu'on est en train de faire quand on
quand on a tenu bon contre les promesses
qu'ils voulaient pas de prix sur la
pollution et quand on continue à
augmenter nos cibles on est là pour
l'ambition mais c'est pas juste
l'ambition c'est la capacité de livrer
les municipalités du canada vous demande
1 2 milliard pour les aider c'est oui ou
c'est non on a toujours travaillé avec
les mains l'idée mais on va le faire
avec les provinces aussi dans le respect
des compétences mais oui ou non le 2
milliards ont besoin de c'est urgent de
2000 y en a déjà envoyé des milliards de
da municipalité on va continuer d'être
là pour rien donc oui à 2 milliards je
vais regarder la demande tels concrètes
mais on a toujours été partenaire avec
les lives et l'on va construire seul
fait de belles et grandes annonces ou si
à côté greta tandberg nul est venu au
delà de l'image qui était projeté de la
promesse était de planter deux milliards
d'arbres
vous en avez planté convient jusqu'à
maintenant on en a planté d'abord planté
des arbres fawful et puis c'est d'abord
ça prend un certain montant pour peut
pas tout simplement par planter des
graines il faut taper des arbres ça va
prendre des années pour c'est au cours
d'un dossier des pensionnats autochtones
maintenant un pensionnat pour les
autochtones la découverte de centaines
de corse a bouleversé beaucoup de gens
mais vous vous étiez au courant quand
même depuis un certain temps puisque
tout ça avait été
rapporté dans par la commission vérité
et réconciliation
qu'est ce qui a été fait depuis 2007 et
2015 donc qu'est ce qui a été fait a été
fait jusqu'à cette découverte est
d'abord en 2017 on ne donnait de
l'argent justement pour permettre à ces
recherches pour retrouver les dépouilles
c'était un 28 milliards de dollars
qu'ils ont commencé à utiliser qui est
en train d'être utilisé cet été mais en
même temps vous allez donner dix fois
plus après un cancer oui quand j'ai vu
de plus en plus de besoins mais
l'important quand j'allais visiter en
saskatchewan a kawa sas pour voir
justement c'était la deuxième communauté
on en avait découvert des dépouilles on
a pu annoncer en même temps la fin de la
dpj pour les enfants autochtones que les
jeunes autochtones aller pour à risque
allait pouvoir rester dans leur
communauté soit ça se fait pas en deux
semaines comme un monstre ça fait des
années qu'on travaille dessus avec les
peuples autochtones pour pouvoir pas
juste pleuré la perte de ses enfants
depuis des décennies mais de dire à
partir d'aujourd'hui ça se fera plus les
enfants à risque vont rester dans leur
communauté c'est seul travail de
partenariat qui se fait pas du jour au
lendemain qui s'est préparé depuis des
années qu'on a pu
heureusement annoncé et démontrer comme
partenariat positif dans un moment de
tragédie terrible est ce que les
responsables s'il y en a qui sont encore
en vie doivent faire face à la justice
est ce que le gouvernement fédéral doit
financer une enquête pour qu'on
comprenne les circonstances entourant le
décès de ses petits enfants oui je pense
qu'on devrait s'assurer que y ait une
redevabilité qui est des conséquences
mais c'est pas un policier de décider si
on dépose des accusations qu'on a lues
en faveur oui je pense que tout le monde
est en faveur de comprendre les horreurs
qui se sont faits et de s'assurer que
ceux qui sont responsables
c'est un travail que je continue à faire
avec l'église catholique malheureusement
qui n'est pas tout à fait au rendez vous
pour faire des excuses ou pour pour
comprendre leurs responsabilités ou pour
prendre prendre acte de leur
responsabilité là dedans on a du travail
à faire et sur la question des droits
territoriaux parce que c'est un peu ça
le noeud du problème avec la loi sur les
indiens mais est-ce que vous avez avancé
sur cette question là puisqu'on se
souvient tous c'est juste avant la
pandémie en l'absence a fait un siècle
mais quand même les revendications de
droits territoriaux des oueds souhaité n
est-ce que ça avance et depuis ou bien
ce qu'on risque de revoir encore des
blocages ferroviaire non ça avance ya
toujours des risques de blocage toujours
des risques de différents mais en même
temps ce qu'on est en train de faire et
ce qu'on a fait c'est de sortir
plusieurs communautés de la loi sur les
indiens à leur rythme en partenariat
pour leur donner le contrôle de leur
propre gouvernement de leur propre
service c'est un travail de longue
haleine ça prend ça prend des années
pour défaire le les torts qui ont été
faits sur dix siècles mais le progrès se
fait à tout là tous les jours y la loi
sont des indiens est ce que ça faudrait
l'éliminer oui vous déjà fixé un but
mais est ce que c'est comment c est ce
que c'est luis et c'est commencer et
c'est fait pour plusieurs communautés et
on a d'autres qui sont pas prêt encore
de le faire selon eux et on avance à
l'heure et ne peut pas imposer des
solutions d'ottawa sur les communautés
autochtones il faut travailler en
partenariat ça prend un peu de temps
mais c'est comme ça qu'on arrive aux
bonnes solutions qui sont générés par la
communauté elle-même donc oui on va en
finir avec la loi sur les indiens mais à
la leur est pas un autre merci mais je
rebondis une seconde là dessus est ce
que de notre vivant parce que votre père
espérait saint jean chrétien qui a été
ministre espérait ça à l'époque est ce
qu'on va voir sa une un nouveau pacte
avec les peuples autochtones au canada
sans loi sur les indiens wii pourront
être propriétaire ou y aura des les
ententes territoriales ce que vous
pensez de notre vivant va voir ça oui
oui absolument peut-être pas à 100% par
tous parce qu'il ya des communautés qui
sont qui ont plus de travail à faire que
d'autres mais il y en a déjà plusieurs
mais communautés qui sont en train
d'être complètement sorti de la loi sur
les indiens qui sont en train de réussir
de façon économique qui sont en train de
contrôler leur éducation leur système de
santé etc des modèles pour pour tous les
autres à suivre et on va être là pour
aider pour financer pour appuyer dans
l'arrière-cour ce trudeau je sais pas
s'il ya deux semaines quand vous êtes
allés prendre un café ou un thé j'en
sais rien avec marie simone une femme
par ailleurs remarquable je peux vous
avez pu dire quelques mots en français
voir si elle prenait des cours de
français avez vous pu ou et j'ai essayé
un peu le français avec elle vous savez
que il ya eu 600 plainte au commissaire
des langues officielles
suite à la nomination d'une femme je lui
dis qui peut être remarquable par
ailleurs mais qui ne parle pas français
quel message envoie aux communautés
francophones de ce pays monsieur trudeau
est ce que vous avez vu le tout tout la
contreverse de cet été est ce que quand
vous regardez en arrière vous êtes
c'était peut-être une erreur non c'était
pas une erreur mais écoutez j'ai
réfléchi longuement à ce choix je sais
que ça n'allait pas être facile à faire
sur le bilinguisme chez toujours là pour
défendre nos langues officielles je les
ai posées aux juges de la cour suprême
par exemple pour moi c'est extrêmement
important mais on est dans un moment
maintenant où je pense que mary 100 m
devait être l'exception et non un
précédent mais l'exception parce que
notre pays a besoin de mieux comprendre
et d'être là pour les communautés
autochtones qui s'il affaire de tous et
mairie ont la capacité de rassembler les
gens et elle s'est engagée à apprendre
le français elle est en train de
travailler neil a grandi au nord du
québec car au moment où on enseignait
pas le français aux jeunes autochtones
et ça c'est dommage ça changeait
heureusement non comprends ça pivote des
et de réconciliation mais vous comprenez
monsieur trudeau et la réaction des
communautés francophones au québec
ailleurs partout au canada qui se dit
ici la gouverneure générale s'est pas
assez important qu'elle parle français
qui sommes nous non je comprends ce
sentiment je comprends tout à fait les
gens qui ont partagé cette cette
réputation et moi aussi je la partage je
voudrais pas que ça devienne à quelque
chose qui arrivent régulièrement mais
dans le moment dans lequel on était on
avait besoin de quelqu'un qui s'engage à
apprendre le français mais qui va être
là pour aider les communautés et le pays
a guéri dans ce moment de réconciliation
si le choix que j'ai fait et je la
sienne mais surtout de la sécurité des
citoyens mise en cause les fusillades
explose on pense à montréal ces jours
derniers ces dernières semaines les
grandes villes vous demande de prendre
vous même à ottawa la responsabilité de
l'interdiction des armes de poing alors
que vous leur lancée ça dans leur cour
et qu'ils imposent un pleur de reprendre
cette responsable et de l'internet
pourquoi pas tout d'abord il faut
comprendre que depuis les débuts on agit
pour renforcer le contrôle des armes à
feu depuis le mois de mai passé c'est
maintenant illégal de posséder d'acheter
ou d'utiliser d'un pardon d'acheter
d'utiliser ou de vendre un arme d'assaut
au canada la sauce effet qu'il ya plus
d'armes d'assaut d'ego au canada ça
c'était une grande étape on va continuer
de prendre des étapes y compris le
travail avec les villes à pour bannir
les armes de poing mais on sait que
c'est pas la réalité à travers le pays
qui est que les gens sont prêts à faire
ça il ya des villes comme montréal comme
toronto qui veulent vraiment et on va en
faire plus pour travailler avec eux
parce que ça paraît incohérent de
laisser à des petits territoires une
telle responsabilité
alors que vous n'hésitez pas à prendre
des politiques pour l'enfant du
territoire canadien pourquoi pas le
faire rapidement c'est une attente
parce qu'on est pas rendu là encore
parce que on est rendu au point où oui
il va falloir qu'on continue de
renforcer le contrôle des armes à feu
les conservateurs veulent remettre sur
le marché les armes d'assaut d'ailleurs
c'est un choix très clair que les gens
veulent prendre on va continuer
d'avancer mais ont retravaillé avec les
villes pour bannir les armes de poing
sur l'arrestation d'un dirigeant de
huawei même où joe les procédures
judiciaires ne sont pas encore terminées
mais une fois qu'elles le seront
utilement est-ce que c'est pas une
décision politique
est ce que vous pourriez ne pas
l'extrader aux états unis qu'elle rentre
chez elle pour sauver les deux michael
qui sont emprisonnés depuis
993 jour aujourd'hui d'abord je déplore
tellement la situation des deux magots
juger par la leurs familles directement
on travaille pour les sortir de cet
emprisonnement et juste depuis les
débuts moi ma responsabilité c'est aussi
de démontrer aux chinois ja à tous les
pays du monde que c'est pas en arrêtant
des voyageurs ou des citoyens canadiens
qu'on va pouvoir avoir le résultat
politique qu'on veut ça peut pas
fonctionner comme ça donc on est pris à
devoir dire que oui on a un système de
justice qui vont suivre son cours mais
non on va pas se pliaient du chantage
pour pour qui il n'est en liberté nos
deux citoyens oui mais c'est pour sauver
des vies et vous avez le pouvoir de le
faire pour sauver la ville la juge
louise arbour avait dit que vous vouliez
même interrompre les procédures c'était
un homme et sa maîtresse que tous les
voyageurs canadiens tous les
travailleurs canadiens qui se retrouvent
en chez nous et ailleurs dans le monde
si les pays savent qu'ils peuvent faire
du chantage pour avoir un résultat
police politique qui désirent en mettant
de la pression sur le canada via ses
citoyens et pour moi de défendre
l'intégrité de notre système de justice
et la fermeté avec laquelle on va
défendre tous les citoyens y compris les
maicon mais aussi tous les citoyens qui
font du tourisme qui travaillent
ailleurs dans le monde faut être ferme
ne l'envisagé pas de ne pas l'extrader
on
va regarder toutes les étapes
nécessaires au travail avec nos
partenaires les pays du monde entier
sont en train de mettre la pression sur
la chine parce que ce qu'ils voient qui
se passe aux canadiennes pour espacer
pour leurs citoyens aussi passé prévu
comme à 10 et les vous avez le droit de
ne pas l'extrader après un processus
judiciaire après le processus judiciaire
il ya des étapes à suivre on va regarder
à ce niveau là mais pour moi ça demeure
des prêts c'est extrêmement important de
protéger tous les canadiens justin
trudeau on a été
impeccable dans le chronomètre mais
heureusement version merci de vous êtes
prêt n'est l'exercice
prochain chef et rennes aux tours
le canada a changé notre parti doit
changer aussi
je suis une chef trop choix et je vais
toujours défendre les droits pour les
femmes de choisi pour elle même point
final les chants 3 climatique est une
menace pour notre société le débat est
clos
on n'a pas reçu des vaccins que monsieur
trudeau a promis à cause d'une approche
il en par le gouvernement ou d'eau là
avec un plan pour les vagues sac si le
temps de pour le premier menu ce2 dit la
vérité ainsi qu'ils consomment les
vaccins pour les fonctionnaires je vais
augmenter les transferts en santé
chaque année sans condition les libéraux
le bloc bleu limpide et les verts n'ont
pas de plan d'eau assurer la reprise
économique après le produit pas de plan
pour l'emploi
tous les nationalistes du québec sont
les bienvenus ou parti conservateur en
afghanistan on a une absence de volonté
pour le titre la réconciliation est une
priorité au moins je vais parler avec
les dirigeants hope town sur notre faim
ensemble on va agir pour l'avenir
c'est tout bon soir merci d'être avec
nous merci pour l'opportunité tout
allait bien je vais bien alors on voit
depuis le début de cette campagne que
vous voulez vraiment recentrer le parti
conservateur vous avez notamment
présenté un plan sur l'environnement
mais ce qui a aimé mais là la plupart de
vos militants n'ont pas voulu
reconnaître l'existence même des
changements climatiques en mars dernier
donc comment ce que les canadiens
peuvent vous faire confiance que vous
êtes sérieux sur cet enjeu de
l'environnement maintenant je suis
nouveau chef avec une nouvelle approche
et les changements climatiques est un
enjeu important pour moi comme une
politiciens mais comme une perte de
famille aussi et ici pourquoi en avril
j'ai lancé notre politique sur le
changement climatique
on va atteindre nos objectifs de paray
paris tout en protégeant les emplois et
on a un plan pour une relance économique
aussi mais les changements climatiques
l'environnement sont importants pour
notre parti et je vais très fort sur le
changement climatique qu'est ce que ça
veut dire que tous vos candidats croient
en l'existence des changements
climatiques même du candidat comme
cheryl gallant qui a propagé les
théories du complot sur le climat tous
nos candidats sont en accord avec notre
plan au début de la campagne j'ai lancé
notre plan pour le rétablissement du
canada avec notre politique sur le
changement climatique
on doit atteindre nos objectifs
c'est important pour notre parti est
d'avoir une relance économique après la
pandémie aussi c'est possible d'avoir
les deux et je vais travailler très fort
sur tous nos politiques c'est le temps
pour un plan d'action sur les emplois et
sur l'environnement aussi est ce que ça
veut dire que tous les candidats qui
seraient pas prêts à accepter ce plan
seraient exclues de votre caucus
éventuellement donc tout le monde sont
en accord avec notre peuple je suis fier
de notre là on a lancé au début de la
campagne
on va avoir cinq piliers les emplois une
loi anticorruption la santé mentale un
plan d'être plus près pour les pandémies
et un plan d'équilibrer le budget et les
changements climatiques est une priorité
pour moi comme j'ai dit et on doit agir
sur les priorités alors parlons de ce
plan vous dites que vous allez respecter
les cibles de l'accord de paris
réduction de 30% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais les nouvelles cibles
international du canada ces 40 à 45 % si
vous devenez premier ministre est ce que
vous allez respecter ces nouvelles
cibles canadiennes on a un plan de
d'atteindre nos objectifs de paris et on
doit faire ça mais surtout d'eau a
manqué ses objectifs
chaque année pas premier naissent comme
promener c'est inacceptable et canadiens
des québécois méritent un plan réel on
doit réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre tout en respectant une
relance économique après la pandémie et
on va travailler avec les provinces sur
ça on a beaucoup de détails dans notre
plateforme sur
l'environnement le changement climatique
comme j'ai dit je vais travailler avec
les provinces pour nos objectifs mais
est-ce que c'est 30 ou est-ce que c'est
40 30 maintenant parce que on doit
atteindre nos objectifs
et c'est la même chose pour nos alliés
aussi il y a beaucoup d'ambition mais
pas un plan concret j'ai lancé un plan
concret j'ai travaillé en étroite
collaboration avec les consultants va
d'avoir un plan real et c'est important
pour notre parti de rétablir la
confiance des canadiens et des québécois
dans notre approche et comme j'ai dit je
suis nouveau chef avec une nouvelle
approche et j'ai travaillé dans le
secteur privé sur les enjeux
environnementaux aussi et c'est
important pour moi personnellement oui
mais sauf que est-ce que c'est suffisant
parce que les états unis par exemple les
50 52 % de réduction la grande
au royaume uni soixante dix huit pour
cent le canada est vraiment en retard là
dessus on en reste qu'il faut pas
augmenter et faire preuve d'un peu
d'ambition à ce niveau là on va voir les
résultats avec nos alliés et on a un
autre utilité d'améliorer nos relations
avec les états unis est de travailler en
partenariat comme monsieur mon rooney a
fait
déjà donc on doit travailler avec un
plan concret canadien et c'est important
d'avoir une relance économique parce que
avec une économie force est possible de
lutter contre le changement climatique
les inégalités la réconciliation on doit
voir une relance à travers le pays parce
que même pour la la la taxe sur le
carbone pour vous cette fois-ci vous
reconnaissez maintenant que c'est un bon
outil pour essayer de réduire les
émissions mais vous la plafonner à
une taxe de 50 $ pour le parti pour les
particuliers est-ce que c'est pas
seulement symbolique parce qu'au fond ça
va coûter moins cher de polluer avec un
gouvernement trop leurs prix sur le
carbone et c'était un changement pour
notre parti bien sûr mais c'est très
important pour notre pain d'atteindre
nos objectifs et tous les canadiens et
canadiens avec notre plan va comprendre
leur un prêt carbone et on doit
travailler ensemble les familles les
fermes les entreprises et les grands de
métaux aussi et on a un plan avec
beaucoup d idées sur les changements
climatiques et c'est important pour
notre parti d'atteindre nos objectifs
combien de nouveaux pipelines vous
voulez construire au canada monsieur
autour pour sortir pour exporter le
pétrole de l'alberta les emplois honneur
bretons sont importants il y à une crise
de confiance dans notre pays maintenant
après six ans de monsieur to do et on
doit rétablir la confiance dans l'ouest
30 ce matin est un oléoduc très
important de l'avant avec vous mais nos
digues et oui aussi c'était un exemple
d'une partenariat avec les premières
nations là-bas mais monsieur trudeau a
amusé et ce en concertation avec les
profanations c'est vous qui vous
voudriez construire le nord est est une
est un gars diot de colo deux importants
mais les deux sont suffisants parce
qu'on voit quand même que dans votre
plan que vous voulez encore développer
cette industrie pétrolière yapo question
fait comme si de rien n'était on
continue malgré les feux de forêt malgré
tout ce qu'on l'a vu cet été les
canicules il faut aller de l'avant vous
dites avec l'industrie pétro doit agir
sur le changement climatique tout en
respectant l'économie et les les
familles canadien dans le west au québec
mérite une relance économique et on doit
réduire nos émissions et je vais
travailler avec les grandes émetteurs en
alberta dans les autres industries pour
un plan d'être carbone neutre par
2050 c'est très important pour notre
pays est ce que vous pourriez imposer un
pipeline comme celui d' énergie s par
exemple au québec parce que quand vous
étiez dans la course à la direction du
parti vous vouliez une nouvelle un
projet de loi qui autoriserait le
fédéral a imposé les pipelines partout
au canada est ce que c est ce qu on
pourrait voir un autre pipi les les les
oléoducs
et noir d'une gouaille son importance et
mes priorités et on doit rétablir la
confiance des canadiens dans le west
dans notre pays après six ans de
monsieur to do il y a plus de divisions
dans notre pays et on doit travailler
ensemble pour une relance économique et
c'est pourquoi je vais respecter les
jambes des compétences des provinces et
leur bien-être comme une économie et c
je suis fier de nos secteurs à deir
ezzor ce naturel dans l'oise le bois
d'herve ici au québec a les mines aussi
nous sommes plus vert que tous les
autres pays dans le monde vraiment droit
on doit travailler en étroite
collaboration avec les les entrepreneurs
les entreprises pour réduire les
émissions et avoir une relance
économique donc pour ce soit clair
est-ce que vous ne garantit qu'un n'aura
pas vous exclut pas qui revient on va
cibler sur à 30 et nordine ben oui
seulement donc il n'aura pas au québec
oui on doit travailler en partenariat
avec les provinces j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour eux mêmes une s le goût on
a eu dire des réunions on a parlé sur la
langue la culture
québécoise on doit travailler ensemble
sur une relance économique et les
priorités en commun
il y avait un projet de jeu reprend la
balle au bond y avait un projet mais
surtout d'un pipeline vers le québec est
ce que vous pourriez l'imposé c'est ça
la question non je vais travailler avec
les provinces incluant monsieur legault
on doit travailler ensemble après six
ans de divisions comme j'ai dit si une
province comme le québec veut pas de
pipeline n'y aurait pas de pipeline non
parce que on a des pipelines très jeunes
le west vous avez ça m'offre hâtez vous
venez de citer mulroney on est au québec
monsieur ma journée est-ce que vous
citez monsieur mulroney aussi dans
l'ouest est ce que c'est une inspiration
politique pour vous monsieur mulroney je
suis un nouveau chef et j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour tous les personnes enrôlées
tech à et je pars avec les anciens
dirigeants de notre parti incluant
monsieur mouse est particulièrement sur
la situation avec nos relations avec les
états unis ont droit à améliorer la
situation
c'était c'est cette mauvaise situation
avec les tarifs sur le droit des peuples
à les buy american l'annulation de
criston aligne 5 il y à des risques avec
nos relations a maintenant et on doit
améliorer ça monsieur autour vous avez
dit je suis pro choix point final a été
de me pose la question je suis pro choix
n'empêche vous voulez laisser aux
médecins
choix de refuser de faire pratiquer des
avortements
comment s'assurer que ça ne va pas
restreindre l'accès à l'avortement dans
certaines régions où il ya plus de
médecins comme comme vous le savez je
suis pochoir je vais toujours défendre
les droits des femmes pour deux choisi
pour elle même et l'accès à l'avortement
est un service important à travers le
pays et sa soeur et mon approche comme
premier ace protéger les droits des
canadiens à travers le pays en
partenariat avec les provinces parce que
je vais augmenter les transferts en
santé avec une montant historique 60
milliards de dollars pour notre système
de santé public et universel mais sans
condition j'ai dit ça avec communiste
legault c'est une question de respect
mais les services sont jouées mondiale
on va vous parler de sentiment d'une
seconde mais juste pour bien comprendre
parce que dans votre course au
leadership
javier dit on n'obligera pas un médecin
a référé à un autre médecin meetic veut
pas pratiquer un avortement on ne
l'oublient je repars référé un autre
médecin là vous avez changé d'idée donc
là vous êtes d'accord qu'on oblige les
médecins s'ils veulent pas pratiqué à
référé un médecin qui veut pratiquer à
n'avoir jamais gagné la course à la
chefferie comme un candidat trop choix
et je vais avoir une approche comme
quand même naissent pro-choix et l'accès
à l'avortement et est important c'est
une doigts et on doit respecter ça c'est
c'est possible d'avoir des
accommodations raisonnable pour les
médecins ou les infirmières avec les
services de l'aide médicale à mourir
mais l'accès et les référents sont
importantes dans notre système public il
ya quarante députés de votre caucus qui
sont pro vie vous avez quand même il
faut le souligner gagné leadership avec
le vote
religieuse bout pour simplifier est ce
que vous pourriez nommer un député pro
vie comme ministre de la santé on a un
chef qui est pro choix et comme j'ai dit
je vais défendre les droits pour les
femmes g j'ai fait ça comme un officier
dans les forces armées canadiennes
j'étais là pour les doigts de notre pays
pour nos institutions et je vais avoir
un coach comme ça comme tu remets menace
je suis ici pour protéger nounou foyers
nos doigts et a pour la prospérité pour
tous les canadiens tous les québécois
après la pandémie et c'est pourquoi j'ai
lancé mon plan pour le rétablissement du
canada mais je vais dur chaque jour je
suis pro choix et je vais défendre les
droits des femmes les droits de la
communauté lgbt q j'ai un bilan comme
alliés et c'est très important pour tous
les canadiens de comprends je suis ici
pour vos doigts merci monsieur toure
prandelli la quatrième vague s'accélère
risque de s'aggraver selon l'agent de
santé du canada les non-vaccinés
prolonge la pandémie monsieur trudel a
dit que tout à l'heure la quatrième
vague c'est la vague des non vaccinés
vous êtes personnellement vacciner mais
vous êtes d'abord ce soir dans cette
campagne un aspirant au poste de premier
ministre est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'obligation de présenter à la
population une équipe un gouvernement
qui serait exemplaire et qui épouserait
la science
absolument c'est pourquoi chaque jour
j'encourage tous les canadiens tu les
québécois à se faire vacciner les
vaccins sont efficaces cc sécuritaire
c'est très important dans notre lutte
contre la couv et 19 c'est pourquoi ma
femme et moi on a enregistré nos
vaccination pour éduquer les canadiens
je vais toujours
respecté les décisions personnelles sur
la santé et c'est possible d'avoir un
approche avec les tests de dépistage
quotidienne les masques les mesures
sanitaires pour les personnes non
vaccinées mais qu'elle souhaitait pour
votre équipe parce qu'il n'avait pas
l'obligation d'être exemplaire au nom de
la protection de la vie parce que vous
avez des pro-vie d'opposition ce
paradoxe ici mais quand on veut être
premier ministre qu'on va avoir une
équipe patrice vous poser la question
pour un ministre la santé à l'avortement
est ce que vous pourriez nommer une
personne non vaccinés au poste de milieu
de la santé qu'est-ce que ça annonce
comme politiques publiques tous nos
candidats et candidates doit utiliser
les vaccins ou une test dépistage
quotidienne mais c'est important et
j'encourage les vaccinations et c'est
très important à plein d'une pandémie
d'avoir une approche de travailler en
collaboration
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
élection en pleine d'une pandémie à
cause de monsieur to do mais on doit
travailler ensemble et de respecter les
décisions personnelles sur la santé des
cas mais même quand on veut un tri lui
représenter l'ensemble des citoyens la
grande majorité des citoyens au canada
favorise la double vaccination est est
ce que votre leadership sont ici n'est
pas mis en cause de ne pas exiger de vos
candidats
cette double vaccination parce que vous
demandez la confiance des canadiens
absolument et c'est pourquoi nous
obligés d'être le seul à pelé exige et
c'est très important pour tous les
canadiens de travailler ensemble contre
la courbe et 10,9 dans la quatrième
vague on doit utiliser les vaccins les
vaccins sont primordiales j'ai demandé
un approvisionnement suffisant des
vaccins il y a un an mais je vais
respecter les décisions porcinet des
canadiens et utiliser les autres utile
parce que c'est possible d'utiliser les
tests de dépistage rapide des masses des
mesures sanitaires pour protéger les
canadiens tous les médecins à travers le
pays de santé publique les plusieurs
gouvernements et particulièrement le
gouvernement du québec que vous dites
respectais beaucoup puis je vais vous
citer le ministre la santé du québec qui
dit que les non vaccinés prennent la
population vaccinée en otage qu'est ce
que vous pensez de la déclaration du
ministre la santé du québec monsieur
dubé où j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
lui il son travail dans la pandémie mais
on doit éduquer les canadiens et
québécois pas forcé sur les questions
sur le propre santé et je suis un
rassembleur comme une chef à et je vais
toujours encore et j'ai éduqué et parler
en partenariat avec nos médecins nous
nos premiers ministres dans une lutte
contre la pandémie vous demander la
confiance des canadiens vous êtes
aspirants premier ministre dans votre
parti on le dit à leurs yeux des
climato-sceptiques l'an 54% du mmm ont
voté contre la reconnaissance des
changements climatiques on peut ajouter
des vaccinés au cpc qui permettra
peut-être sonné au néologisme on les a
vus dans les manifestations des
militants conservateurs ces derniers
jours exprimer leur rage face aux
mesures et puis à cheryl gallant qui
diffusent de la fausse information
disant qu'ils auraient confinement
climatique alors est comment
pouvons-nous avoir confiance en une
équipe aussi variés dans les dans leur
choix comme j'ai dit je suis nouveau
chef et je vais avoir une campagne
positive
chaque jour et c'est pourquoi j'ai lancé
notre carte à fond on va avoir un plan
pour notre paix après la pandémie et on
doit unir notre pays après six ans de
divisions avec monsieur trudeau et tous
mes candidats et tous mes candidats
devront avoir la même approche une
quarantaine prospectives basées sur
notre plan pour les fêter alors cheryl
gallant vous acceptez qu'elle reste
difficile et depuis je pense au début
des années 2000 vous acceptez que malgré
des des théories complotistes elle soit
il lui députée conservatrice et membre
de votre équipe et vous ne donnez pas de
renier ses propos nous sommes dans une
élection en pleine d'une pandémie
c'était une mauvaise décision par le
premier ministre mais je suis ici comme
un chef avec un plan c'est la même chose
avec tous mes candidats et candidates un
plan pour notre avenir a pas des
manifestations au lard seulement c'était
inacceptable de voir ça avec le premier
ministre on doit avoir un débat sur les
idées l'accord n'entre à venir vous ne
dénoncez pas un terminal de terminer son
chéri gala dénoncé par ses propos on
doit présenter un plan le canadien après
la pandémie c'est et
g2 attend pour tous les membres de notre
patrie mois comme chef et tous nos
bénévoles d'avoir une approche positive
sur la campagne dans les garderies
le gouvernement de m dos a signé des
ententes avec cette province un
territoire 30 milliards pour résoudre
une vers celle de garderie le québec
attend un chèque de 6 milliards si vous
êtes élu premier ministre ce que vous
déchirer cette entente je vais
travailler avec le québec a su lagardère
et sur tulle et où les enjeux importants
pour le québec avec notre plan on va
aider tous les familles québécoises
immédiatement pendant cinq ou six ans
comme mais surtout d'eau immédiatement
et on a un plan d'aidé les familles
pauvres les portes famille
le plus grand en arabe avec un montant
de 75 % de la q2 lagarde était tout en
respectant à le système ici au québec
parce que ça fonctionne très bien et
pourquoi ça ne devrait pas fonctionner
pour le reste du canada selon le centre
canadien pour les politiques
alternatives un crédit d'impôt ça arrive
à la fin de l'année les gens doivent
débourser l'argent tout toutes les
semaines et là ce qui arrive c'est que
ça donne l'illusion votre plan donc
sacré des places en garderie alors que
ça n'en crée pas que c'est ça l'urgence
actuellement de créer des places en
garderie o o avec notre proche on va
voir plus de classe à travers le pays
mais les familles vont prendre les
décisions sur leur sueur comme ce temps
sur la situation pour chaque famille et
on va aider tous les familles
immédiatement pas juste 40 % dans cinq
ans et je vais collaborer avec premier
ministre le gros sur la garderie sur un
autre en cela en santé sans conditions
et surtout les enjeux importants pour
les québécois québécois c'est pourquoi
j'ai lancé notre plate forme est aussi
j'ai lancé mon contrat avec les
québécoises et les québécois sur mon
engagement ma vision pour un fédéralisme
de partenariat l'ancien gouvernement du
canada c'est vraiment pour nous estime
que 300 mille femmes pourraient se
rendre sur le marché du travail s'il
avait accès à des services de garde or
pour plusieurs encore une fois les
crédits d'impôt ne crée pas de places en
garderie qu'est ce que vous répondez on
va voir parce que avec notre coach les
familles vont avoir plus de flexibilité
prowler circonstances et pour les heures
de travail tu es le travail les
décisions pour la famille et on doit
respecter les familles et donner l'aide
immédiatement petit clairement pour les
familles à faible revenu on va donner un
montant de 75 % et comme j'ai dit je
vais collaborer avec un menu ce logo
parce que j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
le système ici les provinces demandent
donc la foncière oriente et 1,28
milliard tout c'est tout de suite là où
est ce que vous le donnez le 28 mai a
tout de suite tout de suite je vais
avoir une réunion avec tous les premiers
ministres dont mais la première 100
jours comme premier ménez et j'ai déjà
dit que je vais augmenter les transferts
en santé par 6 % minimum par freiner
dans une façon un stable prévisible et
sans condition en plus je vais avoir des
investissements pour la santé mentale
des canadiens c'est le troisième palier
de notre plan pour le rétablissement du
canada c'est un enjeu important pour ma
famille baca et moi la santé mentale de
nos jeunes et des investissements pour
les toxicomanes aussi parce que après la
pandémie on va avoir des défis après le
pays avec les féminicides qu'ici au
québec les toxicomanies à la dépression
dans nos gènes et c'est pourquoi c'est
une priorité pour moi comme problème
reste m'est donc vous prononcez pas ça
le 28 milliards parce que c'est ça que
lille prend les milices demande si on a
à voir une croissance économique
6% est un minimum et je vais être là
comme une partenaire mais c'est
important aussi de respecter les
chantiers quand tancés j'ai dit ça dans
ma réunion avec premier ministe legault
sans qu'une décision
de fédéralisme de partenariat sur la
situation dans le cfc rider à les défis
dans notre système de santé on doit
travailler ensemble on a vu des étapes
pendant la campagne parmi surtout d'eau
contre les autres premiers ministres ce
n'est pas un fédéralisme de partenariat
on doit travailler ensemble sur le
bien-être des canadiens des québécois
très bien les juges les juges de la cour
suprême monsieur o toole est-ce qu'ils
doivent être bilingues et ils doivent
parler français et anglais comme par
exemple c'est le cas pour le
vérificateur général ou le commissaire à
l'éthique oui un engagement pour le
français biel a immédiatement ou une
grange engagement sérieux d'apprendre le
français j'ai appris mon français dans
les forces armées canadiennes une
institution fédérale c'est important
donc les compétences pour nos juges est
aussi un engagement et on a vu ça avec
mon club et quelques quelques autres
juges et ça se met ça serait mon
approche c'est la même chose avec madame
100 m j'ai beaucoup de respect pour pour
ces expériences est important d'avoir un
gouverneur général lord octobre mais un
engagement sérieux de
respecter nos deux langues nationales et
c'est pourquoi j'ai un contrat avec les
québécois et les québécoises je vais
protéger la langue la culture l'identité
québécoise comme un partenaire à autour
pour madame simone vous avez vu ça fait
beaucoup réagir au canada dans les
communautés francophones limbes août à
l'eau du pays et tout plein de ça est-ce
que vous pensez que c'était une erreur
et on met pas encore en doute ses
compétences tout le monde sait que c'est
une femme remarquable
j'ai beaucoup de respect
et je sais que c'est possible de
d'améliorer votre français chaque jour
je travaille chaque jour sur mon
français c'est important pour moi et je
vais à
travailler avec madame 100 m et c'est
très important de savoir des dirigeants
autochtones à ce temps là hein parce que
la réconciliation est important pour
tous les canadiens et les canadiennes
monsieur tout le juste une petite
précision pas je pas sûr d'avoir bien
compris votre réponse sur le 28
milliards vous ne vous engagez pas
envoyer un chèque de 28 milliards aux
provinces en santé sans condition on a
compris le 6 % d'augmentation
saucier acquis mais pour monter le
transfert d'un coup vous dites je vais
négocier mais ça sera peut-être pas 28
milliards ça va peut-être beaucoup moins
haut doit négocier comme les partenaires
dans notre pays mais les provinces mary
un approche
prévisible parce que après la pandémie
on doit améliorer notre système les ch
et celle des très rares le système en
général les manifestations mais surtout
vous les avez vus vendredi entre autres
sa empêcher monsieur trudeau de de faire
son événement vous avez dénoncé ça
qu'est ce que vous dites à ces gens là
qui sont en colère
et anne marie faisait référence à sa ya
dans votre partie des gens aussi 5,5
soit totalement en colère qui sont archi
compte la vaccination obligatoire qu'est
ce que vous dites à ces gens là pour
apaiser le débat on a une des marques le
cifor et on doit avoir des débats
respectueux pendant une quinzaines jeu
je n'ai pas le temps pour l'ars
allemands et les actes a comme j'ai vu
ici pourquoi je vais dénoncer les
manifestations comme ça c'est totalement
inacceptable et c'est pourquoi j'ai une
approche positive et j'ai une attaque
pour tous mais des bénévoles d'avoir la
même approche après la pandémie on doit
travailler ensemble comme pays tous les
partis tous les niveaux de gouvernement
sur les défis devant nous si vous voyez
les cas d'hospitalisation
malheureusement bien certaines
prévisions pas très drôle
malheureusement augmenté au pays est-ce
que vous excluez avis toujours de rendre
obligatoire la vaccination pour les
employés fédéraux comme j'ai dit
j'encourage les vaccinations oui mais je
vais respecter les décisions des
canadiens sur leur propre santé et comme
j'ai dit on doit éduquer par forcer et
j'ai la même position que les syndicats
et les dirigeants dans le dans le les
fonctionnaires et monsieur to do as a eu
d'une proche de mélanger les gens sur un
sujet très important comme les vaccins
je suis fier de notre niveau de
vaccination parce que les canadiens à
travailler très fort contre lakovic 19
et on doit continuer d'avoir une
approche comme ça
monsieur o'toole je veux parler d'elle
médicale à mourir vous avez voté contre
le projet de loi qui voulait être
conforme à une décision de la cour
supérieure du québec et qui faisait
suite aussi un jugement de la cour
suprême pour voler médicale à mourir
juste autour de vous si ta joue c'est
l'équivalent d'un régime étatique de
suicide alors si vous êtes élu est ce
que vous allez revenir en arrière est ce
que vous allez restreindre l'aide
médicale à mourir
non c'est un doigt pour les canadiens
les canadiens j'ai des inquiétudes ainsi
que comme sur la santé mentale et les
plus vénérables j'ai travaillé comme une
bénévole comme un ancien combattant avec
les livres terrain avec les blessures
mental et on doit avoir une approche à
sérieux sur la santé mentale mais l'aide
médicale à mourir est une doigts pour
les canadiens et on doit travailler avec
les grues les handicapés les médecins de
trouver un équilibre pour les services
avec l'assentiment des scpi projet
devant notre dos très récent là
que vous a volé riez en prenant le
pouvoir
quand les objets on va on va travailler
avec les médecins 1 parce que comme j'ai
dit c'est un doigt l'accès est un droit
mais avec une augmentation pour les
canadiens avec les conditions même
talent on doit avoir une approche
spécifique parce que c'est une décision
primordiale
une dernière question monsieur autour
pourquoi vous êtes prêts à payer 40 % du
coût de construction du fameux troisième
vial entre québec et lévis ne pas poser
de questions il n'ya pas d'étude qui ont
été présentées ce point un projet qui
fait l'unanimité quand même au québec
pourquoi si vite dire oui on va payer
pour ce c'est un exemple d'une
fédéralisme de partenariat les
municipalités sont en faveur c'est une
priorité pour le gouvernement de
monsieur legault et c'est important pour
les exportateurs pour les entreprises
pour les familles dans la grande région
de la capitale et je vais être là comme
un partenaire avec le même monte à 2 le
tram ou une autre projet pour le
transport en commun et c'est très
important de respecter les priorités sur
le terrain à ottawa on a un approche
avec ça avec monsieur trudeau à toi
c'est tous des ingérences dans les
champs de compétence et après six ans
les canadiens les québécois sont tannés
avec une approche en trois situe tout le
temps et c'est pourquoi nous sommes le
seul parti là pour le troisième lien
c'est une priorité pour la région et
rental merci beaucoup de vous être prêté
à l'exercice vous aussi bonne suite de
campagne merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup prochain chef yves
françois blanchet
j'ai pas l'impression que monsieur tout
doux et c'est d'écrire une page
d'histoire j'ai l'impression qu'il
essaie d'écrire une page de sa
biographie
les différences entre les valeurs
conservatrices des les valeurs
québécoises ne sont pas moins grande ce
matin qu'elle l'était hier
on a besoin que les transferts en santé
soit concret justin trudeau n'a pas à
établir le salaire des travailleurs du
réseau des soins de longue durée au
québec le bilan du premier ministre que
nous en matière de frontières se résume
en deux mots confusion et retards moi je
me permet de soupçonner que par exemple
quand il ya eu trois douzaines de doses
achetées au mois de décembre mais on
était payé le gros prix parce que
c'était peut-être une opération de
relations publiques promouvoir
l'environnement ce n'est pas ça pour
rire s'est créé autrement plus de
richesses
à l'étranger en afghanistan en
particulier le canada était la pâte dans
l'arrière de la puissance américaine des
premières nations sont des nations seule
et a mis
sur un même continent et
rappelons-nous le sur une seule terre
nous avons le devoir
de faire apparaître la ville une folie
seront pas tant un mandat d'opposition
d'un mandat de propositions
monsieur blanchet bonsoir
on est tous de nous accueillir comme
pour les autres chefs dans votre
plateforme le mot indépendance
n'apparaît pas si vous n'en parlez pas
qui va en parler quelques petites choses
dessus dans un premier temps depuis la
dernière élection fédérale biopôle eu de
changement à l'assemblée nationale du
québec l'environnement dans lequel
l'indépendance serait mise de l'avant
par une démarche vers un référendum sur
la souveraineté n'a pas du tout changé
par contre qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est que pendant 2 de façon assez
systématique
on a obtenu ou contribué à obtenir des
gains pour le québec aller chercher plus
de pouvoir protéger une pouvoir affirmer
que nous sommes maîtres le français de
l'avant faire reconnaître la nation
québécoise et tous ces éléments mis
ensemble font en sorte que d'une nation
ne peut que développer le goût d'un peu
plus de ça jusqu'au moment où un vent
qui appartiendront aux québécois ne
s'est pas en moins de trancher sur le
moment et c'est pas atawad tanger sur le
moment mais quand les québécois vont
sentir que ça devienne phone on sort un
bel élan mais n'est ce pas la preuve que
le fédéralisme ne fonctionne non parce
que le fédéralisme c'est essayer tout le
temps d'aller chercher des pouvoirs
essayez tout le temps de protéger des
pouvoirs la souveraineté c'est avoir
d'emblée l'ancien et des pouvoirs je
pense par contre que l'aboutissement
naturel du nationalisme dans bien des
cas c'est en effet l'appropriation de
tous les attributs de la souveraineté en
fondant le québécois 1990 le cnca avait
claqué la porte du grenelle en polonais
puis à vélizy ce pilote marche pro full
refaire
et à ce moment là il ya développé ce
front souverainiste avoir et plusieurs
voiliers seulement s'est pas développé
un front cac est à ottawa j'ai beaucoup
de difficulté avec ce non pas parce que
je manque de sympathie pour un certain
nombre de positions de coalition à venir
québec mais on a vu dans les derniers
jours les demandes du gouvernement du
québec à ottawa ça c'est sorti bien
après certaines des positions
historiques du bloc d'ailleurs qui sont
antérieurs à l'existence même de la
coalition venir québec et la plupart des
positions qu'on met de l'avant ces
dépositions qui sont appuyés sur des
votes unanimes de l'assemblée nationale
donc ça inclut québec solidaire le parti
québécois le parti libéral est bien la
coalition bois québec le fait que deux
formations politiques soient résolument
nationaliste décomplexée tannés de se
faire traiter de reste six son nombre de
choses en commun sur la vision
économique du québec veut pas dire que 1
s'inspire de l'autre veut dire qu'ils
partent d'une place relativement
comparables et s'en vont dans une
direction la différence c'est que nous
on va aller au bout de l'exercice et
qu'un jour le québec soit s'ouvre alors
je reviens à ma première question si
vous voulez aller au bout l'exercice
mais que vous n'en parlez pas de ce bout
d'exercice est à dire l'indépendance qui
va en parler nous dirait très humblement
ceci dans la dernière année mais si je
m'étais mis à parler d'indépendance une
fois par semaine vous auriez peut-être
été parmi les premiers à radier monsieur
blanchet parce que c'est vraiment en
parler d'indépendance en pleine pandémie
et donc à une pandémie ça peut bouger à
québec je les y ai je le répète s'il n'y
avait pas l'ange de souveraineté du
québec je ne serais pas là où je suis
maintenant les premiers du québec
françois legault accuse le npd et les
libéraux d'être au centralisateur
d'après vous ce qui donne un petit coup
de pouce aux conservateurs devenu auto
vous savez à peu près trois semaines un
mois quand monsieur trudeau et monsieur
legault par hasard presque habillés
pareils avait annoncé l'entente sur les
garderies là on parlait d'une brume ans
drôle de mot monsieur trudeau et
monsieur legault et l'oeil quelques
jours monsieur o'toole a pris des
positions de certaines des positions qui
peuvent plaire aux québécois il en était
rendu dans une brume ans entre monsieur
otto les messieurs legault moi j'ai
siégé avec monsieur legault il ya
plusieurs années à l'assemblée nationale
du québec mais je pense qu'on a des
convergences d'idées beaucoup plus que
des convergences de romantisme et si les
idées que l'assemblée nationale du
québec porte et que le bloc québécois
portes vont dans une même direction
ça donne au québec un poids très très
considérable à ottawa et à bien des
égards c'est aussi ça notre travail en
même temps quand monsieur le groupe
accuse donc monsieur trudeau est mal le
parti libéral est en fait d'aider trop
centralisateur et sans le dire que ce
sont pas des bons amis pour le québec ce
serait qu'il meilleur ami pour le québec
et pour vous un petit transiger à taiwan
ont sans équivoque le meilleur ami pour
le québec c'est le bloc québécois
les maternelles et canadiens se
choisissent le gouvernement qui lui
vaudront les québécois ont de nouveau
cette fois-ci l'option d'éviter que ce
soit un gouvernement majoritaire qui
détruirait détruire et pardon un nombre
considérable des acquis des deux
dernières années tout le monde a reconnu
l'influencent puis je ne nous
revendiquons des mérites exclusif la
mêle influences qu'on a eue sur la
politique québécoise sur la politique
canadienne au bénéfice du québec depuis
un an et demi deux ans des compromis qui
n'aurait jamais existé sans la présence
du bloc québécois il ya un risque
important prenez l'exemple des
glyphosate parce qu'il vient facilement
et on dit écoutez on va suspendre la
décision sur les glyphes ozap mais
jusqu'en 2022 les libéraux sont
majoritaires
bien le bonsoir on va ramener la hausse
des seuils de glyphosate est gros comme
intrigue en faisant toute votre liste de
genk sont très nombreux dans votre
programme des agriculteurs les fonds de
retraite l'assurance emploi et tout ça
vous fait par le biais même un peu le
bilan d'un gouvernement libéral
minoritaire
alors je demande encore une fois le
meilleur ami pour vous est ce qu'un
gouvernement minoritaire conservateur
ça vous inscrire au moins j'ai la
prétention que qui que ce soit qui soit
au gouvernement si c'est un gouvernement
minoritaire on continuera à faire des
gains pour le québec et je dirais que
deux types de
revendications de mérite qu'on se donne
du sud de trucs qui viennent carrément
nous on la protection de l'ue minium ça
vienne nous autres la protection sur les
fonds de pension comme créant supporters
ça vient nous organisons si vraiment
nous autres il ya des choses où on était
essentielle pour que les libéraux y
arrive la loi de mise en oeuvre de leur
propre budget n'aurait pas été adopté
sans le soutien du bloc le premier
discours du trône rep a été adopté sans
le soutien du bloc la loi c-10 que
malheureusement le sénat se permet de
bloquer n'aurait pas été adopté et non
même pas dans sa forme qui protège le
français la nouveauté sans le rôle du
bloc des fois ci en collaboration parce
qu'on est un parti qui dit encore si
c'est bon pour le québec on est pour 6
est mauvais on est content et on essaie
d'améliorer sa table pour que ça serve
le québec mais monsieur blanchet pour
poursuivre sur cette lancée qui serait
meilleur pour les intérêts du québec un
gouvernement minoritaire rouge ou un
gouvernement minoritaire bleus se
leurrer l'impression de m'ingérer
vous n'avez pas d'avis sur les
programmes sur les propositions c'est
pour servir le québec je suis prêt à
travailler avec n'importe qui c'est ce
qui en sommes donc j'aurai j'aurais de
la misère avec ceux qui font un fonds de
commerce de mépriser les québécois mais
outre cela je pense qu'on a réussi à
collaborer parfois avec les libéraux qui
enrichira collaborer parfois avec les
conservateurs je ne suis pas très
sensible aux chants des sirènes des
conservateurs en matière de transferts
en santé 60 milliards c'est sur 10 ans
et 6 % de hausse par année et si ce que
les premiers ministres ont déjà dénoncé
en disant c'est pas assez longue et il
faut voir il faut aller au fond des
vraies affaires enlevée 6 milliards au
québec sur les garderies pour le donner
à moscou est fort ce qui nuit
expressément au québec c'est un problème
refuser la transition énergétique
ça reste un problème à être pro choix
dans un parti qui n'est pas pro choix
c'est un problème dire aux médecins qui
seront obligés sauf problème être
content et
j'ai mieux faire des propositions
logiciel legault vous a bien dit a bien
vu quand même aux québécois mais il y
ait deux parti centralisateur regardez
écoutez bien ce qu'ils ont à dire ses
chefs et ses il a ouvert la voie il a
ouvert la porte lundi ben ayed deux
parties est vous qui allez conservateur
donc il est exact je le reconnaît
facilement les conservateurs ont une
approche moins centralisatrice que les
libéraux et le npd est ce que ça veut
dire que les conservateurs servirait
mieux le québec sur des éléments
fondamentaux de l'économie ou de
l'identité dé quoi je n'y crois pas les
conservateurs sont pas en faveur des
transferts en santé demandée ils sont
pas en faveur du transfert sur les
garderies qui était proposé son poids en
faveur de l'augmentation de l'aide aux
aînés qu'on a fait et qui reste
absolument fondamental ils sont pas en
faveur de permettre au québec de
procéder à sa transition économique
énergétique parce qu'ils veulent
continuer à soutenir d'autres de l'ouest
donc il reste des différences majeures
entre la entre l'original et la copie
sur les éléments programme du bloc
québécois ben je suppose que les
québécois pourraient s'intéresser
d'original mais iliad il ya des choses
en commun comme vous ils sont en faveur
du troisième bien
j'ai dit que je n'étais pas il faudra
s'entendre oui mais là je pose la
question vous je vous fais ni station
très courtes très joli tous conviennent
de l'urgence climatique
puis il faut être cohérent
l'environnement doit être le critère
d'analysé de tous nos projets à partir
de maintenant je blanche et quel est le
potentiel écologique du troisième lien
je n'ai pas encore comprise elle sait
jamais très très souple ne cherchant que
vous avez à vous il avait pris
la décision qui va traverser seul d'un
coup la décision relève de québec le
road fédéral et de transférer les
cendres que demande québec dans les
demandes toute récente du premier
ministre hugo c'est transfert en bloc de
toutes les sommes relatives aux infos
structure québec
juridiction québécoise à presse à québec
et responsable des évaluations
environnementales irresponsable des
consultations publiques irresponsable
d'obtenir l'acceptabilité sociale il est
responsable de faire en sorte que le
projet soit le plus écologique possible
qu'est ce que j'ai dis qu'est-ce que je
redis ce soir ça se peut ça se peut le
potentiel est là mais c'est à québec de
faire mon travail mon travail est de
protéger les juridictions de l'assemblée
nationale du québec qui à l'intérieur
aurait des accords puisque en montrant
qu'ils voudront parce que c'est un peu
normal mon travail n'est pas demain j'ai
ri mais je sais que ça peut être fait de
façon
passablement ou beaucoup plus écologique
décision qu'elle ne relèvera pas de moi
vous continuez à dire monsieur blanchet
qu'un potentiel
écologique passe au pied pour des
raisons économiques sociales qu'on
veuille faire un tunnel très bien mais
de dire que c'est un potentiel
écologique ce que vous reconnaissez que
vous êtes allé un peu trop loin extra
fort en café en pl je ne crois pas je
vais vous donner deux exemples dans les
jours qui ont suivi j'étais
à part ça nulle part saguenay ont été
l'objet d'un rapport de pêches et océans
canada qui disent il faut pas qu'il y
ait un bateau de plus qui parle sur le
saguenay condamnant le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean a pu de
développement économique terminé la
principale voie pour sortir ses sauts
pour l'instant tellement que la mairesse
de saint denis disait il ya des
entreprises qui nous disent on va s'en
aller ailleurs quand j'étais ministre
environnement à l'époque quoi qu'en dise
monsieur guilbeault je disais ce que je
dis encore aujourd'hui on ne doit pas
opposer le développement et
l'environnement on doit concilier le
développement et l'environnement et dans
le contexte actuel les dizaines de
milliards qu'on coule dans le pétrole de
l'ouest doivent être investis dans un
énorme chantier de transition écologique
de transition économique qui vaut créer
plus de richesses qui vont ouvrir des
marchés par l'innovation plutôt que
d'être ceux qui traînent la patte au
niveau environnemental en continuant à
soutenir en disant contraire le pétrole
de l'ouest je compte vous disiez ça
passe ça m'amène à l'autre question
monsieur blanche on a l'impression
vous avez parlé de votre passage comme
inès de l'environnement quant au québec
on sait que ça pollue moins si marina
guinness forage anticosti vous ouvrons
version du pétrole gnl vous êtes on va
attendre le bab mais je pas contre mais
on va attendre le bas quant à
l'extérieur du québec c'est le pétrole
sale quant au québec les projets prover
ils sont acceptables
j'adore tellement les questions d'abord
anticosti parce que si la décision d'y
aller d'y aller n'était pas la mienne
mon travail était d'être le protecteur
là dedans et j'avais dit à l'époque je
serai dans les bottes les compagnies
pour que ce soit fait le mieux possible
j'ai toujours été convaincu comme j'ai
dit de nombreuses fois depuis que ça
pouvait pas être rentable que la
restauration environnementale par le sud
n'était pas possible et comme de fait il
s'est jamais rien passé avec ça mon
travail il me donnait pas le pouvoir de
dire à la premier ministre vous irez pas
là il me donnait une certaine autorité
morale pour essayer de mettre des
paramètres de la protection dans le
dossier de par daniel lio trois semaines
un mois j'étais au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean je suis allé
voir une entreprise se développe et du
charbon biologique du bio charbon le bio
charbon et carboneutre mon entente avec
mc innis à l'époque toute la partie on
n'a pas respecté notre parole on nous
demandait des centaines de millions ça
rien à voir avec moi la partie
environnementale de négocier une entente
que 40% de la production énergétique
viennent de biomasse forestière
résiduelle locales ce qui en aurait fait
s'il avait respecté leur parole la
cimenterie qu'on continue à utiliser la
plus écologique au monde quoi qu'en dise
monsieur guilbeault dans le score
environnementale et pas très
impressionnants non plus
mais pas répondu sur une aile si ce même
projet l'avait été dans l'ouest the rule
mêmes réponses en disant on va entendre
le bape on peut pas être content dès le
début c'est le deux poids deux mesures
j'essaye de géorgie s'invite humblement
à consulter les bulletins de nouvelles
de ya quelques semaines où j'ai dit gnl
n'ont jamais eu l'acceptabilité sociale
gnl n'a jamais eu de financement jeunes
elles n'ont jamais eu de clients c'est
vrai depuis le début et j'avais dit à ce
moment là c'est terminé avant même que
ce soit tiré la plogue si j'avais
terminé gnl les gens se sont fait mener
en bateau la région du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean au droit à un
autre type de développement économique
beaucoup plus porteurs et durables
trente secondes monsieur blanchet
pénurie de main d'oeuvre vous voyagez au
québec c'est en campagne les gens
doivent vous parlez de ça les
commerçants les restera tout le monde
tout le temps qu on fait quoi plus negra
qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya plusieurs
solutions possibles au problème de la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre dont j'ai
exactement comme vous partout on aux
propositions sont déjà sortis à cet
égard ou d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs
pistes de solutions d'abord la pcr eux
était un remède à un mal qui à bien des
égards n'existe plus c'est à dire que ça
servait à donner un pouvoir d'achat
nécessaire à des gens qui ne pouvaient
pas faire le travail qu'ils avaient
auparavant à partir du moment où tout ce
monde peut retourner au travail la pcr
n'est plus une mesure nécessaire sauf en
culture ou c'est très très long revenir
au travail c'est une position que je
défends je demande pas l'abolition je
demande la suspension parce qu'une
quatrième vague pourrait demander qu'on
réactive le programme les incitatifs à
garder les jeunes retraités sur le
marché du travail plus longtemps c'est
important il faut travailler sur les
haies statistiques autres jusqu'auquel
super pote on supplément de revenu
garanti finie la seule immigration plus
ou moins est-ce que ce que vous croyez
que c'est une jeune et papa du nombre
des migrants je n'ai jamais eu peur du
nombre des migrants qu'on accueille le
nombre d'immigrants qu'on accueille est
tributaire de notre capacité et de nos
efforts pour les intégrer notre première
responsabilité c'est de leur donner le
principal outil pour s'intégrer
la maîtrise du français parlé de la
quatrième vague on voit que québec
impose la vaccination obligatoire aux
travailleurs de la santé le gouvernement
fédéral lui veulent imposer aux
fonctionnaires fédéraux cette
vaccination
y at war pourquoi vous opposez à ça est
ce qu'on est pas rendue à ma première
dénonciation là-dessus était due au fait
que monsieur trudeau voulait escamoté sa
décision d'élections précipitées
derrière un coup d'éclat qui était de
dire on va obliger la vaccination de
tous les travailleurs fédéraux se
faisant d'emblée il rentrait dans la
juridiction du québec et de toutes les
provinces parce que la santé publique
est une juridiction des provinces et du
québec en sus de ses propres
fonctionnaires supérieurs avait dit y en
a qui voudront pas il y en a qui
pourront port l'alternative c'est le
test à l'entrée il y avait des manières
de le faire qui correspondait aux
recommandations de l'appareil public
fédéral mais monsieur trudeau voulait un
coup d'éclat de démarrage sur lequel
vient 6 beaucoup moins et vous ai dit
tout à l'heure à eau mais au moins dans
les transports on va le maintenir mais
bien six buts plus beaucoup sur la
fonction publique qu'est ce que québec a
fait dans sa juridiction au moins dans
le système de santé on voit s'il s'en
tenir à ça on verra plus tard mais dans
système de santé c'est la moindre des
choses qui en mon âme et conscience je
disais que c'est très raisonnable que
les gens du système de santé soient
vaccinés donc vous dites vous n'avez pas
aimé la manière dont ça a été fait mais
vous n'êtes pas contre la vaccination
obligatoire je ne suis pas favorable et
ça c'est un peu
comme une incertitude récente des choix
de monsieur trudeau il ya des gens qui
craignent
qu'ils craignent la vaccination à temps
à mon avis sans l'ombre d'un doute qu'un
il faut les informer le mot éduqué il me
semble un peu condescendant mais il faut
les informer il y en a qui vont
continuer à être réfractaire à ça mais
la bonne manière de le faire c'est pas
de dire vous êtes des franches et c'est
pas de dire je ne reculerai jamais puis
s'était pas de commencer la campagne
électorale en dix ans joue à toulouse
obligé une façon quand tu es chef d'état
avec la responsabilité d'être
rassembleur d'avoir une approche plus
pédagogique un approche de corps une
fois de coups d'éclat pour rallier un
électorat qui vous rapproche ou aller
plus loin serait monsieur tour de cette
position mais est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que ça peut braquer les
gens est ce que ça peut être une cause
qui braquent en fait les gens qui sont
encore hésitants qui sont récalcitrants
l'obligation ce que je crains c'est ce
que je crains ce l'asie que ça nous je
ne me rapproche pas de la position
monsieur tout le monde a eu des votes
avec les conservateurs à de nombreuses
reprises puis des fois c'est un d'autres
initiatives il faut c'était à la la
c'est le charme d'un parlement
minoritaire
suivons avec les formations politiques
et tu réussi à construire des consensus
comme on l'a vu au début du mandat avant
que ça devienne plus partisan vers la
fin du monde libre ou humaine dans une
chose que j'ai découvert cette semaine
avait reconnu la contribution du bloc
québécois au programme de début de
pandémie il avait même fait une liste de
ce qu'il disait on est ouvert à vos
recommandations on ne doit être possible
est ce que vous seriez en faveur de
sanctions contre il faut que
fonctionnaires fédéraux qui refuseraient
non là c'est dans l'ordre que je trouve
que c'est délicat encore une fois j'ai
pas l'impression que de dire je vais
vous sanctionner pour quelque chose
d'impossible parce que ses propres
fonctionnaires à monsieur trudeau dit
écoutez c'est pour ça qu'on recommande
aussi que des gens qui peuvent penser
que des gens qui veulent penser que des
alternatives possibles pour arriver là
et au détriment des recommandations de
ses propres experts monsieur trudeau en
rajoute une couche en disant je vais
vous sanctionner alors qu'il ne sait
même pas comment il pourrait procéder le
chef libéral justin trudeau il promet
aussi des milliards en santé pour les ch
et celle des mais il va imposer des
normes nationales vous vous êtes contre
il ya quand même des gens monsieur
blanchet qui doivent se dire après avoir
vu tout l'hécatombe danser dans ces
maisons pour aînés pendant la première
vague la deuxième vague qui doit se dire
que peut-être que c'est pas une si
mauvaise idée que ça d'avoir des normes
nationales est-ce que sont
inacceptables que ça on a des normes
nationales ce sont celles de la nation
québécoise dans notre système de santé
la santé est un juridiction du québec
tout le monde tombe un peu dans le piège
le npd totalement pour centraliser vers
ottawa c'est une pression irrésistible
de monsieur trudeau mais monsieur où
tout cela disait moi je transfère sans
conditions mais j'ai un enveloppe que je
réserve puis j'oubliais que ce soit pour
la santé mentale alors que ci dessus
mais de l'argent sans tête envoie
l'argent québec québec au la compétence
constitutionnelle la compétence père et
de gérer système de santé c'est
forcément la proche des plus efficaces
l'approché plus rapide envoyer l'argent
gens qui ont la responsabilité et la
capacité de mettre en oeuvre les
politiques et je ne vois pas je ne vois
pas en quoi des normes fédérales
seraient supérieures meilleur de quelque
façon que ce soit à des normes
québécoises je ne connais rien qu'un
casier soit capable de faire et qu'un
québécois soient incapables de faire
pourquoi faut-il croire candidement que
parce que ça viendrait du canada ce
serait meilleur que ce qui vient du
québec
monsieur grand chez les autochtones pour
proposer l'abolition de la loi sur les
indiens monsieur trou d'où nous est
aussi tout à l'heure vouloir l'abolir
éventuellement cela dit est ce que cette
abolition ne vient pas en contrepartie
d'une chose importante qui doit vous
toucher de très près c'est la concession
de territoire le territoire québécois et
sacré est ce que pour vous si on
d'abonnés avoir serré ça vient
effectivement avec des territoires
concédé au canada comme au québec nous
avons l'obligation en regard de
l'histoire et de nos comportements à
l'endroit des premières nations d'adn
est le fait que nous coexistions sur 10
même territoire les territoires
revendiqués sur des bases
traditionnelles par les premières
mentions sont pas des territoires où ils
disent on veut que les gens s'en aillent
c'est pas ça leur rhétorique c'est pas
ça leur volonté alors allons-y dans la
séquence le canada dit on adhère à la
déclaration des nations unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones ça vient
avec des conséquences législatives
nécessaires qui sont pas complétés pour
l'instant ça nous on ira après ça il ya
un processus et le chou est assez
d'accord avec le l'affirmation à l'effet
que ça se fait progressivement mais
progressivement veut pas toujours dire
lentement bambins lentement ou bine bine
bine lentement il est exact aussi que ça
se fait de nation à nation donc une
nation à la fois ça peut être plusieurs
en parallèle on n'est pas obligé de dire
toi tu es le numéro 43 on peut procéder
il ya peut-être des nations qui vont
vouloir travailler de façon concertée
avoir une voix plus forte à la table
tout ça est tout à fait admissible mais
il faut d'une part que la volonté soit
là qu'il faut enlever l'ingrédient
paternaliste quand est arrivée la
situation où on en révéler publiquement
parce que comme il le dit lui même le
premier ministre savait déjà qu'il y
avait des c tout était mon cachet
enfouis depuis tellement longtemps
les restes de jeunes enfants autochtones
une position était de dire aux nations
autochtones dites nous ce que vous
voulez nous allons le déposer à la
chambre des communes on le fait adopter
de façon unanime et il s'agissait de
faire tout sauf dictée avec un espèce de
prétention du super élite et voici
comment vous allez procéder mais on peut
plus résister on va mettre l'argent
là-dedans pour va vous dire de faire ça
comme ça il appartient à chacune des
communautés autochtones de faire s'ils
recherchent l'eau et beaucoup ne veulent
pas les faire ses recherches l'ont ils
veulent vivre leur deuil d'une façon
différente il faut respecter ces
différents cela est ce que le territoire
québécois doit rester tel quel est ce
que s'il y avait des négociations avec
des communautés autochtones vous
pourriez accepter que l'on sait des
territoires
en contrepartie de l'abolition
universelle banque de sons personne ne
parle de ça ça n'existe pas le canada
n'a pas assez des territoires c'est pas
des partitions territoriales c'est la
coexistence de nations qui sont ici
depuis parfois des dizaines de milliers
d'années et des colonisateurs européens
et de toute l'immigration qui est venu
par la suite qui coexistent sur un même
territoire quels seront les droits
différencier accordés aux uns et aux
autres dans cette coexistence là tout
l'enjeu est là mais il n'y a pas d'enjeu
de partitions de ça ça n'existe procédé
dans la rhétorique de personnes je
rencontre des nations autochtones
partout sur le territoire et à ne jamais
eu une qui m'a parlé de ce ça n'existe
pas dans leur vision des choses ce
blanchet vous souhaitez un gouvernement
minoritaire
la dernière fois en octobre 2020 une de
vos conditions pour appuyer le
gouvernement s'était que ce le fameux
transferts la facture de la santé 35%
que le fédéral paye 35 % de la facture
ensemble
est ce que la prochaine fois ça sera la
même chose qui soit bleu ou rouge peu
importe vous avez dit que vous n'êtes
pas de préférence est ce que ça sera
votre condition
dur comme fer
d'une part je me permettrai l'occasion
pour rappeler que la demande de toutes
les provinces et du québec c'est 35% des
coûts du système de santé plus une
hausse de 6% par un effectivement
puisque personne ne propose et c'est
pourtant la demande monsieur trudeau ni
mesure d'un propose le vin lui dire une
chose et son contraire d'une part je ne
présume pas de la composition du
prochain parlement mais la tentation
d'en faire une condition doit être très
très forte à très forte parce que parce
que ça fait tellement longtemps que ses
demandes et tout le monde tergiverse les
gens s'imaginent que parce qu'on dit les
mots transferts en santé oms va apaiser
les demandes du gouvernement québécois
alors qu'elle est précise et les
chiffres ips et on sait pas une patente
en gouvernement céder les attentes en
chirurgie c'est des soins comme pour les
gens ont dû sélectionner trois mois
monsieur blanchet même ça veut dire des
excès misera le gouvernement à négocier
comme on le fait pendant deux ans on
aurait pu le faire pendant quatre ans
parce qu'on faisait des gains ont
respecté la volonté des québécois ont
respecté la volonté des canadiens on a
amélioré un grand nombre de choses une
des pires a fait puisse arriver c'est un
gouvernement majoritaire parce que dans
le contexte actuel majorité l'avaient
correspondent à une forme d'arrogance de
l'état central un gouvernement
majoritaire qu'il soit bleu ou rouge
comme patrice tente l ouverture totale à
cela dit je reviens quand même cette
idée que votent pour le bloc
ça pourrait aussi être vote qui
favoriserait le passage d'un
gouvernement conservateur donc le vote
pour le bloc est pas toujours utile pour
certains du kt et
la multiplication des épouvantails en
campagne électorale c'est une pratique
bien connue dont bien sûr on dit parfois
si tu votes pour les libéraux de ce fait
passer des conseils pratiques
moi je dis aux gens voter pour ce que
vous voulez voter pour ceux qui disent
que vous avez envie d'entendre voter
selon le temps selon votre cas selon vos
convictions sur votre analyse la réalité
moi pour ma part je sois libéral
conservateur si ces minoritaires je
pense qu'on va tirer notre épingle du
jeu ils françois blanchet merci beaucoup
bonne fin de campagne et vous aussi
merci infiniment merci des 27 cantons et
au brésil prochain chef invité jack
médecine
nous sommes vraiment parti fondé par les
travailleurs et travailleuses
on veut s'assurer qu'on a une salaire
minimum de 20 $ au niveau fédéral
on veut investir dans un avion ce
médicament universel on veut augmenter
les transferts on voit que justin
trudeau dans les belles paroles mais
c'est où les actions concrètes on va pas
seulement avoir des vaccinations man et
war au niveau fédéral mais on veut avoir
un tas de l'inde en septembre comment on
peut croire maintenant qu'un gros noms
qui a acheté nos lits duc doit
maintenant dire qu'on va avoir des
cibles progressisme npd qui vont mettre
fin finalement au second son pétrolière
et faire face à la crise climatique
je pense qu'ils les conservateurs manque
le coup avec cette question de l'accès
aux services d'avortement
l'êta a tué les enfants autochtones
et les blessures le trauma continue de
s'assurer que les autorités ne juste pas
c'est la justice de faire ça et puis
investir dans les gens voilà la vision
du npd pour une société plus juste et
plus égalitaire
monsieur singh bonsoir françois vous
avez bien oui oui mais si jamais la
campagne j'adore la campagne j'adore
leur utilité jazz avec légende écouter
leurs histoires et partager des
solutions
il ya des gens qui se posent la question
est qui nous pose souvent la question
pourquoi je voterais pour le npd si les
politiques ensuite sont semblables aux
libéraux on a l'impression que vous êtes
l'élu gauche parti libéral et il vous
volent constamment certains de vos idées
cette campagne dix jours de congés payés
vous aviez proposé ça faire taxer les
banques mais ce tour d'où le proposez
vous l'aviez proposé avant comment où
vous différencie des libéraux monsieur
c'est la grande différence effectivement
c'est pour monsieur trudeau c'est une
des belles paroles mais effectivement ce
n'est pas les actions concrètes qu'on a
vu dans son bilan dans pool nous ce
n'est pas seulement des belles paroles
pour nous c'est des convictions c'est
des choses qu'on veut changer
donc on en parle de la nécessité de
faire pire juste part des autres riches
pour nous c'est parce qu'on ne veut pas
que les pressions tombe sous les épaules
de monsieur madame tout le monde on veut
investir dans les gens donc pour nous
c'est vraiment différent et moi aussi je
suis différent j'ai vécu une vie
différent et je veux aider les gens
donnez moi un exemple très concret ya
des gens la maison qu'ils ont de la
difficulté pour l'achat de maisons pour
le logement se trouver un toit quelle
est la différence en ce que vous feriez
est ce que monsieur trudeau ferait une
bonne question donc ce qu'on a vu dans
les 600 que depuis justin trudeau est
devenu premier ministre on a la pire
bilan pour l'abordabilité des maisons
dans tous les pays de g7 c'est une bilan
assez pire dans ce qu'on veut faire
c'est de faire face aux pics et on a des
compagnies étrangères qui
compétitionnait avec les canadiens pour
acheter une maison c'est quelque chose
qu'on veut tout de suite arrêté justin
trudeau a eu six ans pour le faire mais
après six ans les scot va s'empirer
comment stopper l'augmentation des prix
faramineux de maison donc on a quelques
éléments de ce qu'on veut faire c'est
ainsi de mettre en oeuvre une taxe sur
les investissements étrangers dans le
secteur de achètent des maisons
deuxièmement on veut investir
massivement dans la fabrication des
médias sociaux et abordables donc ça
c'est pour nous le logement abordable et
sociaux c'est primordial parce que on
est vraiment dans un crise et on veut la
règle et je sais que vous en êtes à
votre deuxième campagne est ce que votre
analyse sur ce qui s'est passé au québec
a évolué comment se fait-il que vous
avez été presque rayés de la carte
la dernière fois je pense que les gens
ont fait leur choix et je respect ça
mais ce qu'on a ce qu'on a fait pendant
la pandémie on est montré aux québécois
et québécoises que avec le npd on est
aidé les québécois québécoise on est
montés comment c'est que c'est quoi la
valeur d'avoir des néo démocrates
on a doublé la pcu on a augmenté la
salle à la subvention salariale et en
faisant tout ça on est sauvé des
millions deux emplois et on a aidé des
millions déjà mais monsieur legault vous
disais la semaine dernière vous êtes
trop centralisateur en sentez vous dites
moi les juridictions je veux rien savoir
de ça qui est plus d'argent c'est ça qui
est important et le fédéral doit
investir dans les champs de compétence
des provinces est-ce que ça c'est pas
plus difficile à vendre au québec
si tu peux nous sommes ans de ça je
crois profondément dans les compétences
des provinces je connais ça j'étais
juriste j'étais avocat je comprends ça
mais quand je parle avec les gens qui
ont fait fait ces grands défis les gens
qui ont perdu leurs proches dans les
centres de soins de longue durée quand
je regarde ces gens dans les yeux et
demandent des solutions et pour moi en
ligue 2 c'est quelqu'un qui cherche des
solutions pas qu'ici hd des excuses aux
et on a vu à plusieurs reprises quand je
pose des questions wayne justin trudeau
monsieur trudeau il dans des excuses au
lieu de chercher des solutions mais vous
vous êtes d'accord avec le fait que le
fédéral
dépense dans des champs de compétence
des provinces oui adapté absolument mais
on peut travailler ensemble pour
bâtir meilleur système comment on a fait
avec nôtre soins de santé c'était
leadership au niveau fédéral qui a dit
qu'on peut bâtir quelque chose qui est
meilleur d'un système privé et on a
réussi mais tout en travaillant ensemble
parce que c'est normal on doit la faire
dans un système fédéral on doit
travailler ensemble se saignent la
dernière fois je me souviens vous aviez
dit moi je ne pourrais pas travailler
avec un gouvernement minoritaire
du avec le chef conservateur à l'époque
est ce que monsieur o toole aujourd'hui
vous pourriez travailler et appui au
gouvernement minoritaire conservateur
je comprends la question mais je veux
dire je suis dans cette à l'action pour
gagner dans le nez j'accepte le défi de
la question mais vous répondrai pas mais
je veux essayer de répondre parce que je
n'accepte pas hypothèque ou je perde
d'amis à je ne dis jamais mais je peux
dire c'est quoi la question c'est
essentiellement c'est quoi ma position
sur les conservateurs donc je peux dire
je pense que ça va être mauvais pour les
canadiens canadiennes avec les décisions
des conservateurs je ne veux pas avoir
un premier ministre et un au tube qui va
couper les financements pour les soins
de santé comme harper a fait et comme
justin trudeau a continué très bien
parlant de la vaccination parce que vous
vous prenez la vaccination obligatoire
des employés du gouvernement fédéral et
vous êtes le plus pressé en fait vous
voulez que ça se fasse très rapidement
la semaine prochaine comment ça peut
être mis en place je pense qu'ils ont
droit à la sphère permet mans parce
qu'on doit protéger la population je
pense et nos deux enfants
particulièrement les enfants de moins de
dix ans qui ne peut pas se fait vacciner
eux-mêmes donc c'est important pour la
protection plaît bien commun donc on
peut le faire on doit travailler avec
les syndicats les travailleurs et
travailleuses mais c'est possible et
c'est nécessaire concret et lisette
doute mais vous promettez quand même des
mesures disciplinaires la aux
récalcitrants oui on dit qu'on doit
avoir des conséquences pour les gens qui
ne mettrait pas vaccinés ici important
parce que on sait que cette mesure c'est
important donc on reconnaît les droits
de la personne je suis quelqu'un qui a
défendu les droits de la personne mais
en même temps je respecte énormément les
doigts collective les doigts de bien
commun et je veux protéger les gens donc
on peut trouver une façon d'y arriver
mais est ce que vous pensez vous est-ce
que vous avez les preuves que c'est la
meilleure façon justement de convaincre
cette petite minorité qui hésitent
encore à se faire vacciner parce qu'on
voit les manifestations on voit que ça
polarise quand même une petite partie de
la population j'ai peur de cette
polarisation c'était une bonne question
et j'ai vu l'impact et ça mais je veux
aussi souligner comme vous avez dit
c'est vraiment un petit population il ya
plusieurs personnes qui veut attrait
vacciner mais ils ont besoin dead mon
chef de cabinet m'expliquer que leurs
voisins a voulu être vaccinés mais il
n'a pas eu accès ou internet et ne
savait pas comment le faire donc elle a
aidé et puis elle a elle été vaccinées
donc je pense qu'on peut mettre plus d
énergie des rayures sur aider les gens
qui veut être vaccinés mais qui ont
besoin d aide éducation c'est important
mais on sait pour faire face à cette
pandémie endroit très vacciner il
voulait aussi un passeport vaccinale
fédéral mais le québec a déjà le sien là
on disait monsieur legault dit vous êtes
assez centralisateur qu'est ce que vous
faites c'est seulement en question
d'avoir quelque chose facile quand j'ai
voyagé
dans les provinces atlantiques il y a
quelques semaines avant de l'action
c'était difficile est un peu complexe de
proue de montrer la preuve qu'ils ont
été vaccinées on avait des documents
différents des applications différentes
donc si le gaumont phedra peut avoir un
passeport vaccinale pour voyager
étrangers pourquoi pas avoir une
document simple pour tout le canada si
on veut voyager au canada entre les pays
entre les provinces et territoires parce
que on a des provinces qui dit non on a
des provinces qui dit oui mais c'est
facile d'avoir un document qui peut
fonctionner pour montrer la preuve mais
qu'est ce que vous faites avec le québec
déjà le sien oui oui c'est cool c'est ça
va continuer avec sociaux ne peut garder
la série weeds c'est notre outil pour
aider les gens si on voyage aussi on
visite les gens qui habitent en
saskatchewan où on n'a pas un passeport
vaccinale qu'est ce que vont faire si on
veut voyager au québec donc une document
facile pour rendre la vie plus simple et
facile pour voyager mais c'est une bonne
idée peut-être mais c'est peut-être pas
facile à appliquer la pcr e vous êtes
heures en faveur de la prolonger comme
le fait en ce moment le premier ministre
nos jeux suis en faveur de le prolonger
mais justin trudeau monsieur tu dois à
couper l'aide aux gens et je pense dans
un quartier un vague de la cofidis neuf
c'est la mauvaise chose à faire on sait
qu'il ya plusieurs personnes qui ont
toujours peur peur à perdre des emplois
où les gens qui ne peut pas retourner au
travail qui travaille peut-être dans les
secteurs du tourisme ou du des arts du
culture donc si tu jures un grand
problème pour plusieurs personnes notre
notre position en perspective ces on
sait qu'il ya plusieurs grandes
entreprises canadiens qui ont pris
l'argent public mais qui ont exploité
les systèmes on doit s'assurer qu'il
rassure marc gens au lieu de couper
l'aide aux familles aux gens qui ne peut
pas travailler ni comment vous allez
identifier ces entreprises là on a
quelques mesures pour l'identifier à
mesure c'est assez public qui est il y a
des centaines d entreprises qui ont
donnez l'argent aux actionnaires donc
c'est complètement public mais s'il peut
donner l'argent aux actionnaires ça veut
dire qu'ils ont réussi à avoir une grand
profit donc pourquoi ils ont obtenu
d'argent public ils doivent retourner
cet argent pour moi les grandes
entreprises avec beaucoup d'argent doit
payer le juste prix pas les gens qui
travaillent pas les familles pas les
personnes âgées comme justin trudeau est
lé a déjà coupé l'aide aux personnes
âgées aux gens qui ont besoin de la paix
si heureux en même temps c'est un peu
difficile de changer les règles après
cool vous allez dire aux compagnies
l'argent vous avez fait on va vous
l'enlever mais le problème c'est siegen
une compagnie utilise cet argent pour la
mauvaise foi on doit dire et ce n'est
pas ce que on a vu lui faire avec cet
argent c'était pour garder les emplois
c'était pour aider les travailleurs et
travailleuses et si vous ne les utilise
pas ça pour les bonnes raisons donc on
doit d'y renoncer si mauvais vous devez
leur retourner pour investir dans les
gens qui en ont besoin vous voulez
mettre fin au privé dans les centres de
soins de longue durée mais au québec a
beaucoup de résidences pour personnes
âgées qui fonctionne très bien et qu'ils
n'ont pas été plus visés que d'autres
pendant cette pandémie là alors qu'est
ce qu'elles vont devoir fermer ce qu'on
a vues et sait quelque chose qui me
frappe fort dans cette pandémie je pense
que c'était une honte nationale si les
faits qui sait si nos âges et nos
personnes âgées
nos proches dans les centres de soins de
longue durée qui ont été le plus frappé
par la pandémie et nos forces canadiens
ont investi et ont aidé les gens dans
ces centres est ce qu'ils ont vu les
autres hommes et asie et ils ont des ce
sont des gens qui ont vu des guerres
donc pour moi je veux les aider je pense
que les profits ne pourra pas être dans
les centres de soins de longue durée
parce qu'on sait avec le profit qui a
que l'argent vont aller aux actionnaires
aux exécutive et tout l'argent ne va pas
pour les soins de nos aînés et pour moi
ce n'est pas acceptable mais comment
vous allez faire ça vous allait
nationaliser ces du gouvernement fédéral
qui deviendrait propriétaire comment
voulait fonctionner nous pas de tout ça
mais on peut commencer avec reverra
c'est une entreprise qui est le deuxième
plus grande à travers les pays et c'est
toujours propriétaire du gouvernement
fédéral effectivement donc on peut la
nationaliser mais pour les autres on
peut utiliser
les lois sur les santé canadiens comment
on l'a utilisé dans l'époque pour
changer les hôpital privé en public on
peut utiliser les mêmes lüthi pour dire
si on utilise notre argent public ça
doit aller seulement pour les soins de
nos aînés pas pour enrichir les riches
investisseurs et c'est ce que se passe
maintenant et je veux l'arrêter donc
même celles qui fonctionnent bien
devrait fermer selon vous pas fermée
mais doit changer d'une but lucratif à
une but non lucratif parce que c'est
vraiment ces problèmes on l'a vu tu la
preuve dans les bus du créatif on a vu
les conditions les pires les plus
horribles et je veux éviter ça je veux
aider les gens j'ai parlé avec les
familles qui ont perdu leurs proches et
après l ai pas parlé avec eux ce n'est
pas en question de dire oh ce n'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut faire on doit
trouver une solution
monsieur signe parlons environnement vos
cibles de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre sont celles du giec le groupe
d'experts son environnement et elles
sont plus ambitieuse que celle
du gouvernement trudeau du parti libéral
c'est 50% un peu comme les états unis
non c'est que c'est un pays pétrolier
alors comment il réalise comment
allez-vous y arriver je sais que ça va
être difficile donc je comprends ça mais
je suis toujours optimiste si on prend
les bonnes décisions on peut y arriver
donc quelque chose qu'on peut faire on
peut
investir dans la rénovation
écoénergétique saveurs réduire nos
émissions et aussi créer des bons
emplois on peut aussi investir dans le
transport en commun et électrifier le
transport et finalement on doit investir
dans l'énergie renouvelable et finale
finalement justin trudeau oui il a hélas
ni un prix sur la pollution mais elle a
exempté les grands polars donc pour moi
ce n'est pas acceptable de faire ça on
doit faire face aux grands pôles war les
arrêter et aussi vous voulez mettre fin
aux subventions à l'industrie pétrolière
mais est-ce à dire que vous couriez même
des projets qui servent à la transition
énergétique la différence de ce qu'on
veut faire c'est la proche du
gouvernement libéral justin trudeau est
aussi les anciennes mouvement
conservateur si des données d chaque
blanc aux entreprises et 10 ans vous
devez faire ça ou nous on doit avoir des
garanties fermes si on investit d'argent
ça doit être seulement pour dire nos
émissions pas pour aider les entreprises
qui augmente les émissions dont pour
nous c'est d'arrêter tout de suite les
subventions pétrolière et seulement
avoir des investissements qui réduit les
émissions donc des investissements comme
la restauration des sites pétroliers je
crois que c'est un milliard 700 millions
ces genres de programmes qui seraient
maintenues avec ses 17 une approche
qu'on appuie mais ça doit être avec des
garanties fermes sans cette approche de
la cfl qu'on a vu dans la passé avec
monsieur trudeau mais aussi avec les
conservateurs qu'est ce que vous faites
avec le pipeline fairmont c'est une
bonne question j'ai déjà dit j'ai
désormais prononcée contre ce projet et
si j'étais premier mené ce juge mais
acheter un pipeline je pense que c'était
mauvaise décision mais ce moment avec la
décision on doit réfléchir ceux ci quoi
exactement la position du canada mais ma
position était toujours contre oui parce
que au fond les investissements peuvent
se poursuivre ce sont des milliards de
dollars donc vous feriez d'évaluation
avant de l'arrêter oui on doit on doit
évaluer la situation mais comme j'ai dit
je suis contre mais je vais faire une
bonne décision pour les canadiens et le
fameux troisième y ait entre québec et
les leviers
manifestement content les prêts pour
vous il y en a encore qui étudie alors
ça risque de vous coûter des voix dans
la région de québec selon me 1 pour moi
c'est assez cohérent parce que je dis
clairement je suis pour l'environnement
je veux défendre l'environnement et
c'est un projet qui n'aide pas à la
lutte contre la crise climatique donc
genapi je ne la cuy pas mais on peut
trouver les autres projets qui nous aide
dans la lutte qui est vraiment un outil
essentiel ouais mais le gouvernement de
monsieur trudeau pensait que de penser
avant l'élection examiner ce que patrice
est éteint tout le potentiel écologique
c'est-à-dire peut-être le couloir de
transport en commun est ce que ce sont
des compromis qui vous apparaît très
acceptable avec la troisième ligne ce
qui est proposé non je ne suis pas
d'accord mais je suis toujours ouvert à
travailler ensemble avec le québec pour
trouver comment on peut faire en sorte
pour réduire nos émissions pour investir
dans l'infrastructure qui nous aide dans
la lutte contre la crise climatique j'ai
reconnu j'ai parlé avec plusieurs
enfants des deux jeunes gêne personne
qu'ils disent pour nous c'est la
primordiale question comment on va
garantie qu'on a un avenir ils ont des
inquiétudes et je veux répondre aux
besoins et pour l'alberta comment allez
vous aider l'alberta se sortir des
difficultés économiques oui c'est
difficile on saisit vraiment un temps
difficiles pour l'alberta j'ai parlé
avec les travailleurs dans le secteur 2
d'énergie fossile c'est difficile parce
que leur travail est volatile de temps
en temps c'est bon et ça va bien mais il
ya beaucoup de temps où sa tombe et ils
ont des temps difficiles donc ce que je
veux faire pousser travailleurs je veux
dire le la responsabilité de google et
de gouvernement c'est l'étonnement
libéral mais quand je pense que je
critique c'est quoi mais la
responsabilité du gouvernement dans mon
cas ça va être un gouvernement
néo-démocrate
la responsabilité du gouvernement c'est
d'investir dans l'avenir pour le travail
pour les emplois qui restent et pour le
long terme donc je vais la faire je vais
aider les travailleurs on ne peut pas
avoir une approche pour faire face à la
clim ans qu'il a ça côté les
travailleurs donc on a une partie des
travailleurs on va les aider avez vous
l'impression que vous êtes plutôt comme
vous êtes plutôt à gauche que besoin de
vos propositions font peur davantage que
les inspire confiance non je pense qu'
on est dans une époque différents après
ce qu'on a vécu dans un point et demi je
pense que les gens pensent on a besoin d
aide on a besoin des investissements
dans les programmes sociaux je pense que
plus que jamais les gens sont ouverts
aux idées comme pourquoi les
milliardaires ne paye pas le juste pas
pourquoi ils ont ils ont le droit d
exploiter le système quand monsieur
madame tout le monde paye juste pas
pourquoi amazon ne peuvent virtuellement
aucune taxe au canada je pense que les
gens sont ouverts notre approche qui dit
les gens ne doit pas payer la facture
pour la relance ce sont les les ultra
riches qui doit payer le juste par ce
signe j'ai posé la question monsieur
trudeau plus tôt on lui demande un on a
l'impression que la dette c'est pas
quelque chose qui vous préoccupe
beaucoup or il ya des gens et des jeunes
qui nous écrivent régulièrement dix ans
nous on veut pas être pris avec le poids
de cette dette on a l'impression quand
on lit votre programme que les milliards
ou si s'accumulent à un rythme fou là
vous dites toujours la même chose oui
mais on va faire payer les riches est ce
que c'est alice parce que la dette est
quelque chose qui vous préoccupe oui
bien sûr parce que je sais les gens ils
ont peur parce qu'ils ont vu les mêmes
réponses du gouvernement dit gourmand
dans le passé soit ils couplent aide aux
gens où ils mettent la pression sur les
épaules des gens qui ont déjà sacrifie
si les deux approches on est les seuls
partis avec une approche différente une
troisième option ça c'est de faire payer
leur juste part des autres riches mais
c'est beaucoup de choses on va mettre
fin aux échappatoires et ça peut nous
donner des milliards de dollars de plus
pour est venu on va faire payer leur
juste part des géants du web comme ma
maison est aussi on va mettre un taxi
les sur les régions qui ont des fortunes
de plus de 10 millions de dollars donc
avec tous ces mesures on peut investir
dans les gens mais quand les autres
partis comme les libéraux conservateurs
par des crédits d'impôts ou par des
investissements il ne donne pas comment
ils vont les pays donc ils vont faire
deux choses soit coupé l'aide aux gens
dans d autres catégories où mettre la
pression sur les mêmes personnes on a
une pop proches différents pour revenir
aux premières nations monsieur singh on
l'a vu à quel point c'est difficile
d'essayer de la réconciliation d'essayer
de faire des ges l'eau potable tout seul
les conditions de vie les autochtones si
vous étiez au pouvoir c'est qu'elle
serait la mesure une mesure concrète que
vous pensez qu'il faudrait mettre en
place tout de suite pour améliorer la
vie des autochtones parce que tout ça a
l'air assez conclu je pense que l'enjeu
qui frappe le plus fort et qui est
complètement inexcusable et le fait que
dans un pays du g7 à cette époque avec
les technologies qu'on a c'est
complètement inexcusable que les
communautés autochtones n'ont pas accès
à l'eau potable et justin trudeau a
promis de le faire il y a 6 ans elle a
dit que on va la faire jusqu'à 2021 21
et on fait quand même une une partie il
a dit qu'on ne peut pas réaliser nos
promesses il a brisé sa promesse et pour
moi ce n'est pas acceptable parce que on
et vit dans un pays avec les ressources
avec l'argent avec la capacité de régler
ce problème je pense que c'est
fondamental qu'on assure que les gens on
a accès à l'eau potable de kim ngoc
thanh ont fait face d'écran injustice et
c'est une étape important ce n'est pas
la seule tap mais j'ai parlé avec les
gens discutant là une communauté avec
les enfants qui a jamais bu de l'eau
potable dans leur vie et après parler
avec ses enfants j10 ce n'est pas
acceptable que ça continue je vais la
régler mais c'est quoi c'est un problème
de d'argent ou de volonté c'est un
problème de volonté j'ai vraiment
réfléchi sur cette question parce que
quand justin trudeau a voulu faire
quelque chose là sauter dans la première
semaine de la pandémie et l'ami presque
milliards de dollars pour appuyer les
banques quand ils ont demandé de l'aide
donc il peut faire lé grand chose du
gouvernement s'ils veulent donc je ne
pense pas que c'est une question de
capacité ou de d'argent je pense que
c'était une question de volonté et pour
justin tous aidé mais au théâtre et des
belles paroles mais pour s'était jamais
eu d'engagement concret pour moi c'est
un engagement concret ya un débat
monsieur singh en forme à savoir ce que
ça devrait être un des gf grande
fréquence au tgv lors de la perspective
donc une politique environnementale
quelle est votre préférence où je pense
que le train conférence est quelque
chose qu'on peut réaliser plus vite et
et c'est essentiel la communauté a déjà
demandé ça je pense que dans un pays
assez grand que le nôtre c'est essentiel
d'avoir la capacité d utiliser nos
trains ne se restreint plus plus et je
pense que c'est une bonne chose à faire
tout de suite mais ma rêve c'est
vraiment d'avoir plus des
investissements pour avoir un train à
grand vitesse aussi c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut réaliser mais je pense qu'on
doit commencer avec les trois grands
fréquences en imposant de refus les
moyens d'avoir votre rêve de vie je vais
s'être entaillé plus qu'on en parle oui
c'est ça c'est ça donc les gens ont
besoin de quelque chose tout de suite ah
si on a un tronc de plus grande
fréquence je sais que les gens va
l'utiliser si ça fonctionne c'est bien
j'ai utilisé souvent les trains c'est
excellent mais le problème s'il n'a pas
beaucoup comme horaire et c'est
difficile pour les gens qui veulent
travailler dans un autre vie pour avoir
grondé vue donc si on peut avoir en
train de plus grand fécamp ce ça va
vraiment changer la très belle aux
signes de pénurie de main d'oeuvre on à
part avec tous les chefs beaucoup
beaucoup de gens s'inquiètent
est-ce que ça passe par l'immigration ou
sinon une chose très concrète que vous
proposez là dessus je pense
l'immigration ces huits utile nécessaire
la formation c'est toujours unity
nécessaire je pense aussi les gens veut
travailler dans mon avis les gens veut
travailler ils sont fiers de travailler
me si les conditions de travail ou le
salaire de travail n'est pape n'est pas
bon les gens ont de la misère à
travaille donc pour moi c'est vraiment
les conditions de travail la coût de la
vie si on peut régler ça oui bien sûr
les gens veut travail chaque mécène
bonne fin de campagne merci beaucoup
au revoir et après la pause un ami paul
une partie sérieux professionnel et
organisé il faut être juste un petit peu
plus de courage le courage de choisir
quelque chose différent
notre gouvernement ça fait six ans n'a
pas réussi à réduire les gaz à effet de
serre même par une degré nous sommes les
pires émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
on monte
il ya une crise de logement abordable au
canada
alors maintenant c'est le moment de
créer un prestation d'urgence pour les
locataires résidentiel de bab l'heure
est venue plus n'allons pas reconnaître
diplomatiquement
le gouvernement du taliban
si on veut éviter le pire il faut
assurer que on limite le réchauffement
planétaire
madame paule bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous merci beaucoup j'aime beaucoup la
photo
même toi je vous n'êtes pas beaucoup
sortis de votre circonscription de
toronto c'est d'ailleurs là qu'on vous
joint ce soir vous pensez pas que c'est
un peu risqué quand même comme stratégie
pour une chef d'un parti national de ne
pas faire de tournée nationale justement
en fait je n'ai pas dit que je ne ferais
pas tourné juste que je vais passer le
majorité de mon temps d'omar
circonscription malheureusement avec à
la pandémie et des vagues j'ai pas
vraiment eu l'opportunité de passer
beaucoup de temps avec les résidents et
au final c'est eux qui a choisi qui bat
leur a présenté mais je soutiens quand
même à nos candidats et candidates et on
a une âme on a nous avons déjà des
manières de leurs soutenir avec les
réunions virtuelles et des autres
technologies plus écologique et plus
pratique aussi donc pour vous
l'importance et vous faire élire dans
votre circonscription d'abord c'est ça
pas du tout c'est important à chaque
fois qu'il ya une élection générale
c'est très important d'élire les verts à
parce que on sait que les verts sont d
excellents député a pour les résidents
de leur circonscription
on sait aussi qu'ils ont ils sont déjà
des voix efficace à pour l'environnement
le climat et à les autres politiques
progressistes ou alors le le but
toujours dans une action c'est d'élire
des verts facture au canada mais comment
avaler vous convaincre les canadiens de
se rallier derrière vous quand vos
propres troupes ont du mal à se rallier
à vous je n'arrivais pas à les rallier
ya eu beaucoup de contestations dans
votre parti comment ça se fait que c'est
si difficile pour vous de prendre les
rênes de ce parti j'ai même perdu une
députée là qu'est parti chez les
libéraux j'ai entendu les autres
entrevues et c'était non c'est une
question que vous avez posé les autres
aussi à dans une démocratie et surtout
dans les parties avec beaucoup de
militants a il y a beaucoup de points de
vue à il ya beaucoup de passion à ses
quelque chose à qu'on devrait encourager
à mais quand c'est important surtout
dans les élections
nous sommes un parti qui a ne vit pas à
s'unifier alors oui en ce moment nous
sommes ciblées sur ces élections oui
mais vous dites que ça va bien mais on a
tenté de vous et 20 c on a remis en
question votre leadership on a même
tenté de vous priver de financement
madame paule pour faire campagne dans
votre circonscription
ils sont pas quand même des choses aux
partis vers la
comédie en ce moment je crois que
l'énergie à de nos membres de nos
bénévoles à 2 les personnes les plus
impliquées a le plus à passionner pour
notre parti c'est dans ces élections on
sait que nos chaque parti ont eu leur
histoire de la nuda des personnes qui
ont traversé pour notre parti etc mais a
concédé importants allaient berson là
les uns pour les autres peut-être que
des bijoux de la bisbille dans tous les
partis mais dans le vôtre en ce moment
c'est quand même assez gros ce qui se
passe
en ce moment je vois que des preuves que
les vols allers vers travaille fort pour
un ailier à des verts à je ne je ne vois
pas ce nouveau décrit là en ce moment à
midi notre notre but a le mandat dans
notre constitution c'est toujours
délicat des verts dans les élections
générales à on a besoin des verts au
parlement parce que tout le monde sait
qui travaille fort pour leurs atouts
circonscription et aussi pour les enjeux
qui a sont importants aux canadiens
canadiennes tous les verts qui ont été
élus à haut niveau provinciaux et aussi
au niveau à fédéral ont toujours été a
été réélu alors on en a la preuve qu'il
travaille très fort pour les gens au
canada
alors malin paul à quoi bon un parti
vert alors que tous les partis
politiques maintenant ont des programmes
assez détaillé assez développé
jeumont d'abord nous sommes un parti qui
cherche
voire de collaboration et coopération
alors je suis toujours de commencer avec
dire de quoi nous avons une opposition
avec les autres nous sommes partis à qui
propose à mais surtout en ce moment ce
qui concerne le climat nous sommes le
seul parti qui a propose un plan
crédible un plan qui respecte le sillon
c'est un plan qui va à deux côtés et
réduire nos gaz à effet de serre mais
deux élus et aussi de l'autre côté créé
à une à venir à verte avec une économie
compétitive
malheureusement tous les autres partis
comme les spectateurs ont entendu ce
soir il soutient les all you do qu'il
soutient les aléas projets d'exploration
de gaz et pétroliers et soutien à la
fracturation hydraulique amis
soutiennent des choses housse est
absolument impossible de continuer avec
ces projets et d'avoir à l'espérance de
atteindre nos cibles de réduire nos
gazettes à deux c'est possible c'est 60%
en 2030 est-ce bien réaliste compte tenu
des défis que ça représente absolument
absolument on voit que tous nos
partenaires internationales sont en
train de à 2 à 2 à mettre en oeuvre
mettre en marche à des cibles très
ambitieux on a 27 pays dont l'union
européen qui ont déjà à s'accorder sur
une cible à beaucoup plus ambitieux que
le nôtre arona le royaume uni avec leurs
60 à 18% on a même les états unis
attaquent leur 50 à 52 % alors en ce
moment assez le canada bon c'est le
gouvernement ancien qui est en train de
traîner à et qui malheureusement ne
propose pas une un plan ambitieux et en
ligne avec les autres grands pays grande
économie à l'ibère a sont en train de le
faire mais la fin de l'exploitation
pétrolière au canada d'ici neuf ans ou
quinzaine de 2030 2035 omonia riz non on
n'avait pas dit ça du tout on avait a
comme toujours on propose à un progrès
accélérer à voa vers zéro vers zéro
émission et même à des émissions
négatives mais absolument qui est tout à
fait faisable on parle surtout de de
pivoter vers l'énergie renouvelable
on sait que même l' agence
internationale l'âme d'allergie à il lui
aussi ils ont reconnu que l on doit à
faire faire à
l'utiliser d'utilisation à l'extraction
pétrolière
on veut créer l'infrastructure qui peut
soutenir à une économie verte aussi
c'est le moment à le faire et comme je
dis c'est une c'est une énorme
opportunité à nous sommes le seul des
grands économies qui ne sont pas qu'il
n'est pas en train de saisir
l'opportunité à d'une économie verte
le bloc québécois souhaite un
gouvernement minoritaire on peut penser
que le npd aimerais beaucoup un
gouvernement minoritaire mais un
gouvernement minoritaire même si vous
n'aviez qu'un ou deux députés à la
chambre des communes peut avoir
énormément de pouvoir qu'elle serait
comment l'exercer vous ce pouvoir de
blocage quelle mesure pourriez vous
arracher un gouvernement qui serait la
mesure que vous aimeriez arracher au
gouvernement
ses sermons déjà je me demande dans les
gens au canada se demande pourquoi nous
sommes dans ces élections a et c'est
fort possible que ça va retourner encore
une gouvernement minoritaire c'est
quelque chose que bon je je je je
je bon jeu j'espère que nous aurons
parce qu'on sait que les gouvernements
minoritaires dans l'histoire du canada
ont créé des programmes à important
accord notre système à de santé nos
tracts santé alors am le parti vert a
dans chaque cas chaque parlement va
toujours chercher à des points en commun
de travail que nous puissions faire avec
les autres partis ah et on va essayer
aussi de concentrer à les autres partis
sur un vrai plan pour l'environnement
parce que ce n'est pas une question
partisans à le climat a besoin un plan
ambitieux est faisable à nous l'avons
pas à nous sommes le seul à le proposer
mais on veut travailler à main aux mains
avec les autres partis madame paule
bonsoir qui a le meilleur programme
apport vous évidemment verts qui a le
meilleur programme vert à part vous les
libéraux les conservateurs le npd à m il
faut être absolument honnête avec les
gens à au canada a malheureusement à les
autres partis à le plan a c'est un plan
qui ne restera pas à ce n'est pas
possible on sait que ce n'est pas
possible on sait que le panel
intergouvernemental sur le réchauffement
climatique l'a dit à l'autre jour le
secrétaire général de l'onu aussi ce
n'est pas possible de continuer
d'investir dont les projets à pétroliers
et d'imaginer que nous allons atteindre
même les cibles modeste a déjà piloté je
comprends mais comme vous les chances
que vous former un gouvernement sauf
quand même faible qui halki 2 arrive en
deuxième après vous le kavé évidemment
de meilleurs programmeurs il n'y a pas
de deuxième comptable a de l'avenir de
notre planète il y assez juste oui oui a
pour 1 action à relation aucune action a
pour réduire nos gaz à effet de serre on
ne peut pas continuer à mettre en ligne
de nouveaux projets à deux pipelines ni
à la fracturation hydraulique ni les
émotions pétroliers et d'imaginer que
nous allons atteindre nos cibles
quelques petites questions d'actualité
êtes vous pour ou contre la vaccination
obligatoire des fonctionnaires fédéraux
comme je dis dans mes entrevues a gelé
ce vaccin sont une part compte une
partie clé à de notre à lutte contre la
pandémie à on veut que tout le monde qui
peut être vaccinés soit vaccinée en
l'encouragent - toute ma famille est
vaccinée mais on sait très bien et tous
les partis se très bien que healy a dit
y aura des exceptions des personnes pour
des cons un pion des conditions médicaux
à des raisons qui ne peut pas le faire
il y a et des arrangements raisonnable
pour ces gens on va les créer on doit
aller créer donc on n'aura pas
obligatoire mais on on encourage le plus
possible bien sûr il faut reconnaître
qu'il y à des communautés et six au
canada qui ont été traumatisés par leur
interaction avec le système sanitaire
par exemple il faut reconnaître qu'il y
a des gens qui n'ont pas la possibilité
d'être vacciné parce que ce n'est pas
recommandée par leur médecin alors ah
oui bien sûr oui alors voilà alors il
faut trouver une en option à alternative
raisonnable pour à ces personnes alors
il y aura une option raisonnable
d'accord mais dans la fonction publique
est ce que vous êtes plutôt dans le camp
de ceux qui disent il faut obliger tous
les fonctionnaires ou jettent dans le
camp qui disent comme chez hot ou non il
faut éduquer ne faut pas obliger tient
ou l'autre c'est tellement tellement
attriste comparé dès qu'on compare la du
santé des personnes au canada qu'on
parle de non jeu aussi à fondamental à
ce n'est pas une question des cons c'est
une question d'assurer que les gens qui
peut être vaccinés à sont encouragés de
le faire et ils le font à mais aussi
d'assurer qu'il y à une alternative
parce qu'on sait très bien d'accord on
doit avoir l'alternative madame paule
merci beaucoup bonne fin de campagne à
vous aussi merci beaucoup à vous bonsoir
voila voila c'est fait un deux trois
quatre cinq cellules anne-marie aucune
élection merci beaucoup aux marcheurs
merci aux chefs d'avoir joué le jeu avec
nous oui répondent à nos questions et on
va les suivre jusqu'à la fin et je crois
que ça va s'accélérer enfin c'est une
évidence à partir de maintenant
qui débat débat le 8 septembre prochain
rendez-vous nos collègues de tva on va
le dire un homme en noir cette semaine
également donc là la campagne va veut
pas passer à une autre vitesse merci
beaucoup aux cinq cherche merci beaucoup
à vous à la maison
d'avoir été lents ce soir on se retrouve
donc pouvait journal 24 60 aux cinq
heures claudine bourbonnais vous attend
dans une seconde au téléjournal voilà
c'est fait bonne fête campagne
d'observation
m